THIS IS OUR FIRST HEARING OF THE
WOMEN'S SELECT COMMITTEE ON
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
AND I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
BEING HERE BOTH OUR PANELISTS
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM AND
THERE'S YOU THE CAME TODAY. TO
WITNESS OUR COMMITTEE HEARING.
AND WE'RE FORTUNATE TODAY TO
HAVE A ROBUST SET OF PANELISTS
GATHER TOGETHER WITH US WE'VE A
RANGE OF EXPERTS IN THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE SPACE
INCLUDING RESEARCHERS.
PROVIDERS PATIENCE AND ADVOCATES
AND THEY'RE GONNA SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCE WITH US HERE TODAY.
I WANT TO START BY BEING VERY
CLEAR THAT COMPREHENSIVE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS
UNDER ATTACK ACROSS THE NATION.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IN WASHINGTON HAS
WAGED A WAR ON REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM.
BUT CALIFORNIA'S LEADERS ALONG
WITH MY FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS
UNDERSTAND THAT ABORTION IS
HEALTH CARE AND IT'S ACCESS TO
HUMAN IN ACCESS TO IT IS A HUMAN
RIGHT.
ABORTION ACCESS IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED AND
STATUTORILY PROTECTED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT
CONTINUES TO MAKE STRIDES TO
DELIVER EXPAND AND INVEST IN
SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
INCLUDING SAKE ACCESS TO
ABORTION CARE.
IN FACT IS A HISTORIC ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY PROPOSED
BUDGET THIS YEAR WHICH IS
SITTING ON THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
AWAITING HIS SIGNATURE.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING ALLOCATED
IN THIS BUDGET WILL ENSURE THAT
MORE PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
AFFORDABLE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY AND AN OBLIGATION TO
FIGHT TO ENSURE THAT PATIENTS
AND EVERYONE IN THIS COUNTRY CAN
STILL ACCESS HEALTH CARE NO
MATTER WHAT.
IT'S INCREDIBLY DISHEARTENING TO
SEE A MOVEMENT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO BAN ABORTIONS.
WE'VE NOW SEEN FIFTEEN STATES
BAN ABORTIONS.
IN THE PAST FIVE MONTHS.
WHICH TRUMP IN THE WHITE HOUSE
AND CABIN ON THE SUPREME COURT
STATE POLITICIANS ARE EMBOLDENED
TO REGULATE WOMEN'S BODIES AND
TRY TO FULLY BAND SAFE AND LEGAL
ABORTIONS.
BANDS LIKE THIS GO BEYOND
RHETORIC.
THEY WOULD HAVE DIRE
CONSEQUENCES TO THE FUTURE WOMEN
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THESE BANDS WILL PUT WOMEN'S
LIVES IN JEOPARDY AND THEY'RE
STARTING TO LAND ON GOVERNOR'S
DESKS AT A RAPID PACE.
THIS ISN'T A COINCIDENCE.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO BAN
ABORTIONS OUT RIGHT.
AND IT'S IN IT.
AND THIS IS NOT JUST AN ATTACK
ON ALABAMA OR MISSOURI WOMEN.
THIS IS AN ATTACK ON ALL WOMEN.
THIS IS AN ATTACK ON OUR BASIC
HUMAN RIGHT OF BODILY AUTONOMY.
AND THIS IMPACTS EVERY PERSON
WHO CAN GET PREGNANT.
POLITICIANS ARE DOING THIS IN
DEFIANCE OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHO SUPPORT FOR ACCESS TO SAFE
LEGAL ABORTION IS AT AN ALL TIME
HIGH AND GROWING.
IN FACT RECENT POLLING SHOWS
THAT 73% OF AMERICANS.
SAY THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE ROE
OVERTURNED.
ALREADY ONE IN THREE WOMEN OF
REPRODUCTIVE AGE LIVES IN A
STATE.
WHERE ABORTION COULD BE OUTLAWED
FOR A WAS OVERTURNED?
THAT'S OVER TWENTY FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE.
A PATIENT'S HEALTH SHOULD DRIVE
PERSONAL MEDICAL DECISIONS NOT A
POLITICIANS BELIEFS.
THESE ISSUES ARE BETWEEN WOMEN
AND THEIR DOCTORS.
AND WHILE THE NATIONAL ATTACK ON
ABORTION IS AT THE FOREFRONT OF
MANY MINDS WE MUST ALSO CONSIDER
THAT THIS IS NOT THE ONLY
PROBLEM THE CALIFORNIA PATIENTS
AND HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS FACE.
ADEQUATE STAFFING FUNDING
ACCESSIBILITY ESPECIALLY IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
A SOARING STI EPIDEMIC.
IN SAFETY CONSUMER FRAUD AN
UNACCEPTABLE MATERNAL MORTALITY
RATE FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN
ARE JUST SOME OF THE FEW ISSUES
AND BARRIERS. TO CARE THE
CALIFORNIANS SPACE.
pALL OF THE ISSUES THAT WOMEN
FACE IN REPRODUCTIVE CARE.
I ASKED TO CHAIR THE SELECT
COMMITTEE I WAS VERY SURPRISED
TO LEARN.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN SELECT
COMMITTEE.
HEARING ON WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA.
SEP SIMPLY WE LEARNED THAT THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE IS THE FIRST OF
ITS KIND ACROSS THE NATION.
TODAY YOU'LL NOTICE THE LACK OF
ANY OF MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES.
AS MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT WE
INVITED THEM TO JOIN US.
AND THEY DECLINED.
WE WANT THIS TO BE A BIPARTISAN
DISCUSSION.
WE WANT REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
TO BE A NONPARTISAN ISSUE.
WE INVITE THEM TO JOIN US WHEN
THEY'RE READY.
SO I SPECIALLY WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES ARE HERE TODAY. FOR
THE HARD WORK THEY'VE ALREADY
DEVOTED TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL IN CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
SITTING NEXT TO ME WHO AUTHORED
ONE OF THE STRONGEST LAWS IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
OUR FIRST HEARING TODAY IS MEANT
TO SET A BASELINE ABOUT THE
CURRENT STATUS OF OUR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND HERE DIRECTLY FROM PROVIDERS
PATIENTS AND OTHER EXPERTS ABOUT
WHAT THEY FACE ON A DAILY BASIS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE PRIDE
OURSELVES ON BEING AT THE
FOREFRONT FOR PROVIDING
COMPREHENSIVE ACCESSIBLE
COMPETENT AND COMPLETE CARE FOR
WOMEN.
AND MEN IN THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SPACE.
BUT WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE EXAMINE
HOW THE NATIONAL LANDSCAPE
IMPACTS OUR STATE AS WELL AS THE
UNMET NEEDS THAT STILL EXIST IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
REST ASSURED THIS WILL NOT BE
THE ONLY HEARING OUR COMMITTEE
HOLDS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO DIVING IN
DEEPER ON THE ISSUES PRESENTED
HERE TODAY AND HEARING ZEROING
IN ON HOW CALIFORNIA CAN
OVERCOME THE CHALLENGES IMPOSED
ON US AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
AS WELL AS A SYSTEMATIC CHANGES
WE CAN MAKE TO IMPROVE CARE AT
THE STATE LEVEL.
SO WE ARE.
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU DO HAVE
ANY COMMENTS ONE OPEN WITH
[inaudible]
OFFICE OF I'LL JUST SAY A FEW
WORDS OF THANKS FIRST OF ALL ONE
APPRECIATE.
THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR CHAIR AND
ALL OF THE LEADERS THAT WE HAVE
HERE IN THE ROOM.
ON A TOPIC THAT I THINK MANY OF
US.
DID NOT THINK A FEW YEARS AGO WE
WOULD HAVE TO BE DEVOTING AS
MUCH TIME TO BUT OBVIOUSLY TIMES
HAVE CHANGED -- WHEN I ATTEND
GATHERINGS OF STATE LEGISLATORS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY? ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'M ALWAYS REMINDED
OF IS HOW.
IT IS EASY TO TAKE FOR GRANTED
THE ABILITY TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS HERE IN OUR STATE
BECAUSE IN SO MANY OTHER STATES.
ARE IN OUR COUNTRY -- THESE
RIGHTS AS WE KNOW ARE UNDER SALT --
UNDER THREATS IN CALIFORNIA UP
BECAUSE OF THE WORK OF SO MANY
OF YOU IN THIS ROOM -- WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT SPACE TO CONTINUE TO
LEAD THE FIGHT TO BE ON THE
FOREFRONT OF THE FIGHT AND TO ME --
PART OF WHY I'M EXCITED BE PART
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE IS THAT --
WE DO HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY IN
CALIFORNIA ARE TO LEAD THE
NATION AND THAT IS PART OF OUR
HOPE OF WHAT WE CAN ACHIEVE HERE --
SECONDLY I WANT TO SAY IS --
SINCE THE NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
THE STORIES I HAVE HEARD.
NOT JUST IN MY CITY BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN HORRIFIED
ABOUT WHAT IS POTENTIALLY UNDER
ASSAULT -- THE CHAIRWOMAN
ALLUDED TO THE CRISIS PREGNANCY
BILL THAT I AUTHORED AND I WANT
TO THANK ME ROLLIN PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND OTHERS -- FOR
MOVING FOR WHAT WE THOUGHT WAS
GOING TO BE A SMALL AND NOT A
PARTICULAR CONTROVERSIAL BILL TO
ADDRESS.
FAKE HEALTH CENTERS AND IT
PASSED WITH FLYING COLORS IN --
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN IT
WITHSTOOD CONSTITUTIONAL
CHALLENGES BY -- BY ANTI CHOICE
ACTIVISTS IN FIVE FEDERAL COURTS.
AND THEN DONALD TRUMP WAS
ELECTED AND NO GORSUCH WAS PUT
ON THE BENCH AND THEN THE WILL
CHANGE AND BY ONE VOTE -- WE
WERE UNABLE TO PROTECT.
VULNERABLE CITIZENS OF OUR STATE
IN BEING DECEIVED ABOUT FAKE
HEALTH CENTERS AND THAT IS IN
PART WHY.
IT'S SUPPORT AND SUPPORT FOR US
TO REGROUP TO THINK ABOUT NEXT
STEPS TO THINK ABOUT NEW
STRATEGIES.
AND ALSO SAYS SOME OF IMMIGRANTS.
AND AS THE CHAIR OF THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS ARE TODAY'S
AGENDA IN PART FOCUSING ON THE
PLIGHT FACING IMMIGRANT WOMEN.
I IN IMMIGRANT FAMILIES -- A IN
THE WAKE OF WHAT DONALD TRUMP IS
TRYING TO DO NOT JUST TO WOMAN
AND HEALTH CARE BUT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
ALL OF THESE ISSUES ARE
INTERRELATED.
I IN ALL OF OUR RIGHTS ARE UNDER
ASSAULT AND SO FOR ME -- NOT
JUST BECAUSE WE ALL SUPPORT THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE -- BUT IF YOU
COME AFTER ANY OF US YOU'RE
COMING AFTER ALL OF US WE GOT TO
STAND TOGETHER SO LOOK FOR THE
CONVERSATION I AND WHAT WE CAN
DO TOGETHER.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU SALLY MEMBER CHAU --
SO WE'RE GONNA TURN OUR FIRST
PANEL ON THE PANEL WE HAVE
SHANNON HOVIS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA.
DOCTOR CHRISTINE DEL INDOOR
FAMILY PHYSICIAN AND DIRECTOR OF
THE PERSON CENTERED REPRODUCTIVE.
AND DR JENNIFER YORKERS SOCIAL
DEMOGRAPHER AT THE LEE INSTITUTE
FOR HEALTH POLICY STUDIES I WANT
TO WELCOME ALL OF YOU AND I'LL
GIVE YOU A FEW MINUTES INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND AND GIVE US AN
OVERVIEW.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SHANNON HOW
THIS TIME THE DIRECTOR OF NARAL
PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA.
NARAL IS THE LEADING GRASSROOTS
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
ORGANIZATION NATIONALLY WITH TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
IN CALIFORNIA AND TWO POINT
THREE MILLION MEMBERS NATIONWIDE.
AND THEY'RE ALL WE DON'T OPERATE
OR LITIGATE WE LEAVE THAT TO OUR
PARTNERS AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AND THE ACLU.
RATHER WE ORGANIZE AND MOBILIZE
TO ELECT PRO CHOICE PRO WOMEN
LEADERS.
AND TO PASS PROACTIVE PRO CHOICE
LEGISLATION.
NEVER WORKS TO GUARANTEE THAT
EVERY PERSON HAS THE RIGHT TO
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS
REGARDING THE FULL RANGE OF
REPRODUCTIVE CHOICES.
INCLUDING PREVENTING UNINTENDED
PREGNANCY.
BEARING HEALTHY CHILDREN.
AND CHOOSING LEGAL ABORTION.
THIS YEAR NARAL CELEBRATED ITS
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY.
AND THE FORTY SIXTH ANNIVERSARY
OF ROE V. WADE.
BUT WE ARE NOT A TIME OF
CELEBRATION.
THIS YEAR ALONE MORE THAN THIRTY
STATES HAVE TAKEN STEPS TO BAN
ABORTION.
FROM THE SIX WEEK BANDS IN
GEORGIA AND OHIO TO THE TOTAL
BAN IN ALABAMA THE ANTI CHOICE
MOVEMENT FEELS THAT OVERTURNING
ROE V. WADE IS FINALLY WITHIN
REACH AND THEY ARE BAITING THAT
HAVE AN AWESOME CREAM COURT.
MORE THAN TWENTY CASES ARE
CURRENTLY WINDING THEIR WAY
THROUGH THEIR QUOTES THROUGH THE
COURTS THAT POSE A DIRECT THREAT
TO ROE V. WADE.
MEANWHILE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS REPEATEDLY
TAKEN AIM I REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE.
I KNOW STATE IS INSULATED FROM
THE IMPACT OF THESE TAX.
IT IS OFTEN REPEATED THE
CALIFORNIA HAS AMONG THE
STRONGEST PROTECTIONS ON THE
BOOKS FOR REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS.
THE REALITY IS THAT EVEN IN A
STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA.
WHERE THE RIGHT TO OBTAIN AN
ABORTION AND BEAR HEALTHY
CHILDREN IS ENSHRINED IN OUR
LAWS?
WHERE INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE
REQUIRED TO COVER ABORTION AND
CONTRACEPTION AND DISPENSED
CONTRACEPTION TWELVE MONTHS AT A
TIME
EVEN IN CALIFORNIA WERE MEDICAL
COVERS ABORTION FLOWING TO
PATIENTS AND FAMILY PACKED
PROVIDES COMPREHENSIVE FAMILY
PLAN FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES TO
LOW INCOME WOMEN AND MEN.
MUCH MORE WORK REMAINS TO TRULY
ACHIEVE REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AMONG THE MOST IMMINENT THREATS.
ARE THERE TIMES BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO REMAKE
GOVERNMENT POLICY ON
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
OVER THE LAST TWO AND A HALF
YEARS THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HAS PROPOSED REGULATIONS TO
PROMOTE ABSTINENCE ONLY
EDUCATION.
AND CUT FUNDING FOR TEEN
PREGNANCY PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
PROPOSED REGULATIONS TO ALLOW
EMPLOYERS REFUSED TO COVER BIRTH
CONTROL FOR NEARLY ANY REASON.
JUST BY CLAIMING TO HAVE
RELIGIOUS OR MORAL OBJECTION.
AND IN STATING ENTITLED HIM GAG
RULE WHICH JUST LAST WEEK A
THREE JUDGE PANEL OF THE OF THE
NINTH CIRCUIT ALLOWED TO GO INTO
A FACT.
TRUMP IS ALSO ACTIVELY STACKING
THE FEDERAL COURTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WITH ANTI CHOICE
JUDICIAL NOMINEES.
THE EFFECTS OF WHICH WILL BE
FELT FOR DECADES.
IF THESE EFFORTS BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION CANNOT BE STOPPED
AT THE COURTS.
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO HAVE TO
BECOME VERY CREATIVE.
AND DRAMATICALLY INCREASE OUR
FINANCIAL INVESTMENT IN CLINIC
BASED CARE TO PROTECT AGAINST
THE DEVASTATING IMPACT. TO
CALIFORNIA'S ONE MILLION TITLES
AND PATIENCE.
THE REALITY IS THE CALIFORNIA
ALREADY HAS SIGNIFICANT ACCESS
AND EQUITY ISSUES AND THE
ABILITY TO OBTAIN REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE IS LARGELY DEPENDENT.
UPON ONE ZIP CODE. 43% OF
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE
AN ABORTION CLINIC.
MEETING THE PEOPLE HAVE TO
TRAVEL SIGNIFICANT DISTANCES
TAKE TIME OFF WORK AND GET
FUNDING FOR TRANSPORTATION.
AND THERE'S BEEN A 5% DECLINE IN
PLANNING SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THERE ARE NO
ABORTION SERVICES INVESTED BY
CELL YES TULARE COUNTY OR IN THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY.
BOTH OF WHICH ARE POPULATIONS OF
NEARLY HALF A MILLION.
EVEN FOR MEDICATION ABORTION
WOMAN FROM BY SO YOU HAVE TO
TRAVEL TO FRESNO A FORTY SEVEN
MILE DRIVE EACH WAY.
AT THE SINGLE ABORTION CLINIC IN
BAKERSFIELD NAY REMEMBERS REPORT
MONTH LONG WAITING PERIODS JUST
TO GET APPOINTMENT FOR LONG
ACTING REVERSIBLE CONTRACEPTION
LIKE IEDS.
AND EVEN IN URBAN CENTERS LIKE
LOS ANGELES.
THERE ARE MEMBERS HAVE FACED
DELAYS OF SEVERAL WEEKS TO GET A
PERMIT FOR ABORTION.
A TWO THOUSAND TWENTY IS AT TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN STUDY FROM
ADVANCING NEW STANDARDS AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH UCSF.
FROM THE AMONG MEDI CAL
RECIPIENTS 12% OF WOMEN TRAVEL
FIFTY MILES OR MORE.
AND 4% TRAVELED A HUNDRED MILES
OR MORE FROM MEDICAL COVERED
ABORTION.
AMONG RURAL WOMEN 51% HAD TO
TRAVEL FIFTY MILES OR MORE.
AND ACCESS IS NOT THE ONLY
BARRIER.
WITH THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
UNDERMINING REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
UNDER THE GUISE OF RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY.
THE ANTI CHOICE MOVEMENT IS
GROWING ITS NETWORK A FAKE
WOMEN'S HEALTH CENTERS.
SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS CRISIS
PREGNANCY CENTERS.
THESE ESTABLISHMENTS PRESENT
EVER SOUGHT AS IF THEY ARE
LEGITIMATE CLINIC.
BUT USE MISINFORMATION
MANIPULATION AND COERCION TO
ACHIEVE THEIR SOLE PURPOSE WHICH
IS TO PREVENT PREGNANT PEOPLE
FROM ACCESSING ABORTION CARE.
REGARDLESS OF THE PERSON'S OWN
DESIRES.
CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
FAKE WOMEN'S HEALTH CENTERS.
CONTRASTED TO CALIFORNIA'S ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO ABORTION
CLINICS.
AND BECAUSE THE SUPREME COURT
STRUCK DOWN THE REPRODUCTIVE
FACT ACT WHEN YOU'RE AGO.
NONE OF THESE FAKE CLINICS ARE
PART PRIVATE PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY CALIFORNIANS ABOUT
THE SERVICES THEY PROVIDE.
NOW FOR THE FIRST TIME AND THAT
WORK OF FAKE CLINICS HAS BEEN
AWARDED TITLE TEN FUNDING IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE OVER A GROUP WHICH IS BASED
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DESCRIBES
ITSELF AS LED BY GOD AND HAS
MADE CLEAR IT IS TRYING TO PUT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD OUT OF
BUSINESS.
THEY HAVE BEEN AWARDED AS MUCH
AS FIVE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS.
SIMULTANEOUSLY RELIGIOUS
HOSPITALS ARE LOOKING TO EXPAND
THEIR REACH.
RECENTLY THE UC BOARD OF REGENTS
CONSIDERED EXPANDING A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN YOU CASF.
AND THE CATHOLIC HOSPITAL
NETWORK DIGNITY HEALTH.
WHICH IS THE LARGEST NONPROFIT
HOSPITAL NETWORK IN CALIFORNIA
ALREADY ONE IN SIX BEDS IN
CALIFORNIA IS RUN BY A CATHOLIC
HOSPITAL.
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS FOLLOW
POLICIES CRAFTED BY THE U. S.
CONFERENCE OF CATHOLIC BISHOPS
THAT ENDANGER WOMEN AND LGBT Q.
PATIENCE.
THESE POLICIES CALLED ETHICAL
AND RELIGIOUS DIRECTIVES FOR BED
ALL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES INCLUDING ALL BIRTH
CONTROL METHODS STERILIZATION.
MISCARRIAGE MANAGEMENT ABORTION.
THE LEAST INVASIVE TREATMENTS
FACT TOPIC PREGNANCIES AND SOME
INFERTILITY TREATMENTS.
AND ALL EFFORTS WERE MADE BY
UCSF TO ASSERT THAT THERE WOULD
BE NO CHANGES TO THE HEALTH CARE
PEOPLE RECEIVED.
THE EVIDENCE DOES NOT BEAR THIS
OUT.
DR LORI FRIEDMAN AN ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR FROM UCSF FROM THE
MORE THAN HALF OF OBGYN WHO
WORKING CATHOLIC HOSPITALS FIND
THEMSELVES IN CONFLICT WITH
HOSPITAL POLICIES.
FURTHER XIN COVERED THAT IN SOME
CASES THE CASES ETHICS
COMMITTEES WOULDN'T APPROVE
TERMINATING A PREGNANCY EVEN
WHEN THE MOTHER WAS FACING DEATH.
AS LONG AS THERE WERE A FOETAL
HEARTBEAT COULD BE DISCERNED.
CALIFORNIA MAY NOT FACE THREATS.
FROM EXTREME ABORTION BANS.
BUT THE EXPANSION OF CATHOLIC
HOSPITALS RISKS PUTTING
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE IN
CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA ON PAR
WITH THE LIKES OF GEORGIA AND
LOUISIANA.
OVER THE COURSE OF THIS YEAR
MAINSTREAM NEWS MEDIA FINALLY
BEGIN HIGHLIGHTING THAT THE
STATE'S PASSING EXTREME ABORTION
BANS ALSO PULLED THE RECORDS FOR
HAVING AMONG THE WORST MATERNAL
AND INFANT MORTALITY RATES IN
THE COUNTRY.
A WOMAN IN ALABAMA IS FOUR TIMES.
HAS FOUR TIMES THE RISK OF DYING
DURING PREGNANCY THEN A WOMAN
GIVING BIRTH IN CALIFORNIA.
WE KNOW THAT IF THESE BANDS ARE
ALLOWED TO GO INTO A FACT.
MATERNAL MORTALITY RATES WILL
ONLY RISE FURTHER.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE AMONG THE
STRONGEST PROTECTION FOR
ABORTION CARE.
WE ALSO HAVE THE LOWEST MATERNAL
MORTALITY RATES IN THE COUNTRY.
AND THIS YEAR CALIFORNIA HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BOTH EXPAND
ABORTION CARE TO CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES.
BY PASSING SB.
TWENTY FOUR AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO FINALLY ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
PERSISTENTLY HIGH RATES HAVE
BEEN TURNING WHAT MORTALITY
AMONG BLACK WOMEN BY PASSING US
BEFORE.
SIXTY FOUR THE STATE
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
IS NOT DIRE AS IT IS IN OTHER
STATES.
BUT INEQUITIES IN ACCESS AND
QUALITY CONTINUE TO PLAY
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE.
EQUITY AND JUSTICE MUST BE PART
OF OUR WORK IN CALIFORNIA TO
TRULY BE A NATIONAL LEADER FOR
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME TODAY AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISS SERVICE.
THE STANDARD UP [inaudible]
DOCTOR YEAGER [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER YORKER I AM
A SOCIAL SCIENCE RESEARCHER AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO.
IN THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE I WORK
WITH MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAMS AT
THE BIXBY CENTER FOR GLOBAL
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND THE
COLOR BARLEY INSTITUTE FOR
HEALTH POLICY STUDIES.
WE PARTNER WITH HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS EDUCATORS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
CONDUCT A RIGOROUS RESEARCH ON
ACCESS TO FAMILY PLANNING
SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR THE CHANCE TO
SHARE MY RESEARCH EXPERTISE WITH
YOU TODAY.
ENSURING ACCESS TO CONTRACEPTION
IS AN INTEGRAL PART OF WOMEN'S
HEALTH CARE.
THE BENEFITS OF CONTRACEPTION
ARE WIDELY RECOGNIZED INCLUDING
EMPOWERING WOMEN TO DECIDE
WHETHER AND WHEN THEY WILL
BECOME PREGNANT.
CALIFORNIA HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
A LEADER IN PROVIDING FAMILY
PLANNING SERVICES TO LOW INCOME
WOMEN.
CALIFORNIA SERVES THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF TITLE TEN CLIENTS IN
THE NATION.
AND THE FAMILY PACKED PROGRAM
PROVIDES FAMILY PLANNING
SERVICES TO OVER ONE POINT ONE
MILLION LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS.
HOWEVER RESEARCH SHOWS THAT MANY
WOMEN CONTINUE TO LACK ACCESS TO
CONTRACEPTION INCLUDING THE FULL
RANGE OF CONTRACEPTIVE METHODS
AND MANY ARE NOT USING THE
METHOD THAT THEY WOULD PREFER TO
USE.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH NEARLY ONE THIRD OF NEW
MOTHERS IN CALIFORNIA AT
REPORTED THAT JUST BEFORE THEIR
PREGNANCY THEY HAD NOT WANTED TO
BECOME PREGNANT OR WANTED TO
DELAY GETTING PREGNANT.
IN ADDITION THERE ARE PERSISTENT
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO FAMILY
PLANNING ACROSS RACIAL ETHNIC
SOCIOECONOMIC AND GEOGRAPHIC
LINES.
MY COLLEAGUES AND I CONDUCTED A
STUDY AMONG ADOLESCENTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE FOUND THE
ADOLESCENTS LIVING IN RURAL
AREAS.
HAD LOWER AWARENESS AND USE A
FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES THAN
THOSE IN URBAN AREAS.
WITH THE BEYOND THE PALE PROGRAM
AT UCSF I'M WORKING O IMPROVE
CONTRACEPTIVE ACCESS FOR ANOTHER
DISADVANTAGED GROUP.
YOUNG ADULTS ATTENDING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SERVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE A LARGE
PROPORTION OF LOW INCOME
MINORITY AND FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS.
RESEARCH HAS FOUND THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
IGHLY MOTIVATED TO PREVENT
PREGNANCY BUT THEY HAVE LOWER
RATES OF CONTRACEPTIVE USE THAN
THOSE IN FOUR YEAR COLLEGE.
ADDRESSING THE NEED FOR BETTER
CONTRACEPTIVE INFORMATION AND
ACCESS IS ESSENTIAL FOR HELPING
THE STUDENTS MEET THEIR
CHILDBEARING EDUCATIONAL AND
LIFE GOALS.
MY RESEARCH AND THAT OF OTHERS
HAS FOUND THAT LACK OF INSURANCE
AND COST CONTINUED BE A MAJOR
BARRIER TO CONTRACEPTIVE USE.
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT LED TO A
SIGNIFICANT DECREASE AND THE
UNINSURED RATE IN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER COST REMAINS A COMMON
REASON FOR NOT USING A METHOD OR
NOT USING A PREFERRED METHOD.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY THE CASE FOR
METHODS THAT REQUIRE A
PRESCRIPTION.
MY RESEARCH AMONG YOUNG ADULTS
IN CALIFORNIA ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
THE WAYS THAT FREQUENT BREAKS OR
CHANGES IN INSURANCE COVERAGE
CAN DISRUPT ACCESS TO FAMILY
PLANNING.
WHEN YOUNG ADULTS CHANGE
INSURANCE THEY OFTEN REPORTED
GAPS IN CARE WELL THEY WERE
NAVIGATING A NEW PROVIDER
NETWORK AND LEARNING HOW TO USE
THEIR NEW PLAN?
IN ADDITION THE YOUNG ADULTS
THAT WE INTERVIEWED LACK TO
BASIC KNOWLEDGE AND
UNDERSTANDING OF HEALTH
INSURANCE YOUNG ADULTS ARE OFTEN
CONFUSED ABOUT THEIR COVERAGE
WHICH CAN LEAD TO MISPERCEPTIONS
ABOUT CONTRACEPTIVE COSTS.
THEY LACK YOU FROM THE RESOURCES
TO HELP THEM UNDERSTAND THEIR
BENEFITS AND HOW TO ACTUALLY USE
THEIR INSURANCE TO GET CARE.
AND I WANT TO SHARE A QUOTE WITH
YOU FROM A TWENTY SEVEN YEAR OLD
WOMAN THAT WE INTERVIEWED WHO
HAD RECENTLY GAINED EMPLOYER
BASED COVERAGE FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN HER LIFE.
SHE TOLD US I WAS JUST HOPING
THAT THE NEW INSURANCE COVER THE
BASICS I WAS SCARED WHEN I WENT
TO PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND THEY
TOLD ME MY INSURANCE SHOULD
COVER MY BIRTH CONTROL.
I WAS LIKE THANK GOODNESS
BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING
TO HAVE TO PAY THAT WAS MY
CONCERN THE COST.
PUBLICLY FUNDED CLINICS ARE AN
ESSENTIAL SOURCE OF FAMILY
PLANNING SERVICES FOR LOW INCOME
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY ALSO PROVIDE PROVIDE
CRITICAL PREVENTIVE CARE AN S.
T. I. SCREENING AND TREATMENT.
RESEARCHERS FOUND THAT ONE IN
THREE LOW INCOME WOMEN REPORTED
THAT THEY OBTAINED BIRTH CONTROL
FROM A PUBLICLY FUNDED CLINIC.
FOR MANY WOMEN WHO RECEIVE CARE
AT A PUBLICLY FUNDED FAMILY
PLANNING PROVIDER IT IS THEIR
PRIMARY OR ONLY SOURCE OF HEALTH
CARE.
MY STUDY A FAMILY PACKED
PROVIDERS ALSO HIGHLIGHTED THE
IMPORTANT ROLE THAT THESE HEALTH
CENTERS PLAY IN HELPING
UNINSURED INDIVIDUALS LEARN
ABOUT THEIR INSURANCE OPTIONS
AND NAVIGATE THE ENROLLMENT
PROCESS.
THE NEW REGULATIONS FOR TITLE
TEN WILL SIGNIFICANTLY ALTER THE
PROGRAM AND REDUCE THE NETWORK
OF PARTICIPATING PROVIDERS.
IF CLINICS CLOTHES OR NEED TO
REDUCE STAFF AND SERVICE HOURS
THIS WILL LIKELY REDUCE ACCESS
TO CONTRACEPTIVES AND OTHER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES.
ULTIMATELY THIS MAY HAVE THE
GREATEST IMPACT ON THE LOW
INCOME AND UNINSURED WHO RELY ON
TITLE TEN FUNDED CLINICS FOR
THEIR HEALTH CARE.
IN CLOSING WELL CALIFORNIA IS A
LEADER IN WOMEN'S RIGHT
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH THERE'S AN
ONGOING NEED TO ADDRESS THE GAPS
IN ACCESS TO FAMILY PLANNING
SERVICES.
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME AND
UNINSURED WOMEN AND YOUNG PEOPLE.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY RESEARCH
WITH YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ORDERED DOCTOR
DOWN UNDER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE TALENT OR IF AND I'M A
FAMILY PHYSICIAN FAMILY PLANNING
PROVIDER AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
RESEARCHER AT UCSF.
I FEEL INCREDIBLY LUCKY TO WORK
IN A STATE THAT IS CONSIDERED BY
MY COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
TO BE A REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
OASIS.
WHERE PATIENTS HAVE FAR FEWER
FINANCIAL BARRIERS TO CARE? FOR
BOTH ABORTION AND CONTRACEPTION
THAN OTHER STATES.
AND I THINK YOU OFFER MAKING
THAT A REALITY.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO THINK BEYOND THE QUESTION OF
FINANCIAL COVERAGE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE TO THE BROADER
QUESTION OF HOW TO ENSURE THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE POLICY.
MAINTAINS A FOCUS ON INDIVIDUALS
REPRODUCTIVE AUTONOMY AND HUMAN
DIGNITY.
I WANT TO FOR SHARE WITH YOU MY
DEEP CONCERNS ABOUT RESURGENT
NARRATIVE THAT JUSTIFIES AND
PROMOTES ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE BASED ON FIXING THE
SOCIAL PROBLEM OF POVERTY.
IN OTHER WORDS THE IDEA THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS ECONOMIC INJUSTICE
IN OUR SOCIETY BY HAVING MORE
WOMEN USE CONTRACEPTION AND
THEREFORE HAVE FEWER BABIES.
THIS NARRATIVE HAS BEEN
PROMINENTLY VOICE AS A NARRATIVE
AS A MOTIVATION FOR SEVERAL
INITIATIVES IN OTHER STATES THAT
ARE PROMOTING CONTRACEPTIVE
ACCESS IN THOSE GEOGRAPHIES.
ALL THIS NARRATIVE CAN SEEM
INNOCUOUS AT FIRST IT IS
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE IT DOES NOT
PLACE WOMEN'S HEALTH AND ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE AS A VALUE.
IN AND OF ITSELF.
NO OTHER HEALTH SERVICE RANGING
FROM TREATMENT FOR ASTHMA TO
CHILDHOOD IMMUNIZATIONS TO
TREATMENT FOR DIABETES.
NEEDS TO BE JUSTIFIED BECAUSE IT
SOLVES SOCIETAL PROBLEMS.
WHY IS A SERVICE THAT ONLY WOMEN
NEED ANY DIFFERENT AND WHAT
MESSAGE DOES IT SEND ABOUT THE
VALUE WE PLACE ON REPRODUCTIVE
AUTONOMY WHEN IT IS SEEN AS
NECESSARY TO JUSTIFY PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE?
THAT FACILITATES THIS A TIME TO
ME ON THE BASIS OF SOCIETAL
BENEFIT.
RATHER THAN BENEFIT TO WOMEN
THEMSELVES.
AN ADDITIONAL DAY ADDITIONAL
DANGER OF THESE NARRATIVES IS
THAT BY FRAMING WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS THE
SOLUTION TO POVERTY.
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTION IS BY
DEFAULT ALSO CONSIDERED THE COST
OF THIS PROBLEM.
AS A RESULT WE CAN BE DISTRACTED
FROM THE REAL NEED FOR ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL PROBLEMS PROGRAMS THE
TRULY ADDRESS THE CAUSES OF
ECONOMIC DEPRIVATION.
FURTHER THE IDEA THE BY FIXING
THE PRODUCTION WE CAN FIX THE
SOCIETY HAS A LONG AND SHAMEFUL
HISTORY.
LOOTING THE HISTORY OF COURSES
STERILIZATION IN CALIFORNIA THE
TARGETED WOMEN HIS REPRODUCTION
WAS SEEN AS UNDESIRABLE.
NAMELY WOMEN OF COLOR AND POOR
WOMEN.
A NARRATIVE THAT WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTION IS CAUSING THE
PROBLEM CAN EASILY SLIP INTO THE
NARRATIVE THAT IT IS CERTAIN
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTION THAT IS
CAUSING THE PROBLEM.
AND LEAD US TO PROBLEMATIC
POLICIES AND PRACTICES SUCH AS
THE COURSE OF STERILIZATION
SCENE IN THE CALIFORNIA PENAL
SYSTEM IN THE LAST DECADE.
OR LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS TO
INCENTIVIZE OR REQUIRE WELFARE
RECIPIENTS TO USE SPECIFIC
CONTRACEPTIVE METHODS WHICH WERE
SEEN IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES.
THIS NARRATIVE AROUND WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTION ALSO HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO INFLUENCE CLINICAL
CARE WHERE WE'VE INCREASINGLY
SEEN PROVIDER PROVIDERS PROMOTE
USE OF HIGHLY EFFECTIVE METHODS
THAT ARE PROVIDER CONTROLLED
SPECIFICALLY INTRAUTERINE
DEVICES AND CONTRACEPTIVE
IMPLANTS.
IN PROBLEMATIC WAYS AND RESIST
REQUEST BY PATIENTS TO HAVE
THESE DEVICES REMOVED.
EVEN MORE CONCERNING WE HAVE
EVIDENCE INCLUDING STUDIES DONE
BY MY TEAM AT UCSF.
THAT THIS PRESSURE TOWARDS
SPECIFIC METHODS IS
DIFFERENTIALLY APPLIED WITH
WOMEN OF COLOR BEING MORE LIKELY
TO HAVE THESE METHODS
RECOMMENDED AND TO BE PRESSURED
TO LIMIT THEIR FAMILY SIZE.
POLICY MAKERS IN CALIFORNIA CAN
THEREFORE CONTINUE OUR STREETS
STATES TRADITION OF VALUING AND
UPHOLDING REPRODUCTIVE AUTONOMY
BY PUSHING BACK AGAINST THIS
FRAMING OF WOMEN'S HEALTH CARE
AS A MEANS TO A SOCIETAL AND
INSTEAD WE CAN MAINTAIN OUR
FOCUS ON WOMEN'S RIGHT TO HEALTH
CARE.
AND THE VALUEOF THEIR
REPRODUCTIVE AUTONOMY.
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT
REPRODUCTIVE AUTONOMY IS
THINKING CRITICALLY ABOUT HOW WE
JUDGE THE SUCCESS OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AND
POLICY.
THERE IS AN INCREASE MOVEMENT
AWAY FROM THE CONVENTIONAL FOCUS
ON PREVENTING WHAT IS CALLED
UNINTENDED PREGNANCY AS THE SOLE
GOAL A FAMILY PLANNING PROGRAMS
AND POLICIES.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT THE
CONCEPT OF PREGNANCY PLANNING IS
NOT UNIVERSALLY SALIENT OR
DESIRABLE FOR ALL WOMEN.
AND THAT JUDGING WHETHER
PREGNANCY IS CONSIDERED GOOD OR
SUCCESS BY WHETHER IT IS
INTENDED OR PLANNED CAN THE
COLLECT THE REAL FEELINGS OF
WOMEN ABOUT THEIR OWN
PREGNANCIES.
IN WHICH A SURPRISE PREGNANCY
MAYBE WELCOME OR EVEN DESIRABLE.
IN OTHER WORDS TREATING THE
CONCEPT OF AN UNINTENDED
PREGNANCY IS A UNIVERSALLY
NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOME IN THE
SAME WAY THAT A STROKE OR INFANT
MORTALITY IS A NEGATIVE OUTCOME.
DOES NOT HONOR THE ASPECT OF
REPRODUCTIVE AUTONOMY THAT
ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS TO FIND FOR
THEMSELVES WHAT IS DESIRABLE
WITH RESPECT TO REPRODUCTION.
WELL THIS PROSELYTISING
UNINTENDED PREGNANCY AS OUR SOLE
METRIC OF SUCCESS IS DEFINITELY
CURRENTLY ON THE CUTTING EDGE IN
OUR FIELD.
I ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO THINK
ABOUT HOW THE FOCUS ON PREGNANCY
INTENTION IS REFLECTIVE OF AN
OVERLY SIMPLISTIC AND
PRESCRIPTIVE MANNER WE HAVE OF
THINKING ABOUT AN ACTING ON
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE CAPACITY.
MOVING FORWARDS WE ARE WORKING
TOWARDS NEW METRICS THAT MORE
COMPREHENSIVELY ADDRESS HOW
WOMEN THEMSELVES FEEL ABOUT THE
REPRODUCTION.
INCLUDING CONSTRUCTS SUCH AS
PREGNANCY ACCEPTABILITY AND
REPRODUCTIVE QUALITY OF LIFE.
WE ALSO CLEARLY NEED TO PAY MORE
ATTENTION TO THE DEGREE TO WHICH
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS
FOCUSED ON THE PRIORITIES OF
PATIENTS AS OPPOSED TO CLINICAL
SYSTEMS OR OTHER INSTITUTIONS.
THIS INCLUDES PROVIDING
CONTRACEPTIVE COUNSELING THAT
PRIORITIZES WOMEN'S OWN NEEDS
AND PREFERENCES WITH RESPECT TO
REPRODUCTION AS OPPOSED TO
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS DESIRE TO
HAVE THEM USE THE METHOD THEY
CONSIDER TO BE THE BEST METHOD.
IT ALSO INCLUDES ATTENTION TO
IMPLICIT BIAS AND HOW THAT CAN
SHOW UP IN REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
TARGETING WOMEN OF COLOR.
FINALLY I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
ESSENTIAL NATURE OF NOT JUST
THINKING ABOUT ABORTION AND
CONTRACEPTION WHEN THINKING
ABOUT REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH POLICY
BUT IN FACT THINKING ACROSS THE
REPRODUCTIVE LIFE COURSE.
AS WOMEN OF COLOR ACTIVISTS MADE
CLEAR IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES
WHEN THEY FOUNDED THE
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE MOVEMENT.
REPRODUCTIVE AUTONOMY IS NOT
HONORED WHEN WE ONLY LOOK AT THE
QUESTIONS OF THE QUESTION OF
WOMEN'S ABILITY TO CHOOSE NOT TO
HAVE CHILDREN.
WE MUST ALSO PAY ATTENTION TO
WOMEN'S ABILITY TO HAVE THE
CHILDREN THEY WANT AS WELL WELL
AS THEIR ABILITY TO RAISE THOSE
CHILDREN'S AND SAFE ENVIRONMENTS.
POLICIES CONSISTENT WITH THIS
PERSPECTIVE INCLUDE THOSE
ENSURING RESPECTFUL MATERNITY
CARE FOR ALL BIRTHING PEOPLE.
AS WELL AS PUBLIC FUNDING OF
INFERTILITY SERVICES.
ONLY BY THINKING ABOUT PEOPLE'S
REPRODUCTIVE LIVES MORE
HOLISTICALLY AS OPPOSED TO
SEILING OUT ABORTION AND
CONTRACEPTION CAN WE ENSURE AND
HONOR THEIR REPRODUCTIVE
AUTONOMY.
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP AND
TAKING THIS TYPE OF PERSPECTIVE
WAS SEEN IN THE FIGHT OVER THE
MAXIMUM FAMILY GRANT RULE.
I HOPE THIS VISION OF HONORING
AND SUPPORTING REPRODUCTIVE
AUTONOMY ACROSS THE REPRODUCTIVE
LIFE COURSE.
CAN CONTINUE TO ANIMATE AND
MOTIVATE OUR REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
POLICY MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ALL FOR FRAMING THIS
CONVERSATION OF SUCH A POWERFUL
WAY.
I WOULD OPEN UP TO MY COLLEAGUES
GIVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
PANELISTS [inaudible]
NEW.
I WILL I WILL I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL.
FOR COMING AND PARTICIPATING IN
THIS SELECT COMMITTEE AND I WANT
TO THANK THOSE IN THE AUDIENCE --
FOR SPENDING YOUR THURSDAY
AFTERNOON OR LATE MORNING WITH
US TALKING ABOUT A CRITICAL
ISSUE I'M PROBABLY -- I SHOULD
JUST SAY I'M BIASED WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS ISSUE I MAY PROUD
BOARD MEMBER ON PPL WAY -- IN
I'M IN COMPLETE CONTROL OF MY
BODY ALWAYS.
BUT I I WANTED -- TO ASK A
QUESTION BASED ON YOUR COMMENTS
DR BECAUSE I TOO AM WONDERING
WHAT TRENDS DO YOU SEE ACROSS
OTHER STATES ALTHOUGH I KNOW
MANY OTHER STATES ARE.
SORT OF LESS FLEXIBLE -- THAN
OURS BUT WHAT TRENDS DO YOU SEE
HAPPENING IN TERMS OF HOW WE CAN
NORMALIZE THE CONVERSATION
AROUND -- REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
AND FAMILY PLANNING IN A WAY
THAT'S ACCESSIBLE TO ALL WOMEN
ALL KINDS OF WOMEN ALL AGES I
STILL THINK TO YOUR POINT THAT
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FAMILY
PLANNING WERE OFTEN TIMES -- THE
ASSUMPTION IS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ABORTION -- BUT IT'S MUCH
LARGER THAN THAT IT'S HELPING
YOUNG WOMEN UNDERSTAND.
SYSTEMS AND NETWORKS AND
PROVIDERS IT'S BEGINNING TO TALK
ABOUT HOW THE INFORMATION -- IN
THE AMBASSADORS TO HEALTHCARE
INFORMATION MIGHT NOT BE AS
CULTURALLY SPECIFIC -- AS WOMEN
WOULD LIKE THEM TO BE IT'S
HAVING HONEST CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT HOW WOMEN ACTUALLY FIRST.
GET INFORMED ABOUT FAMILY
PLANNING -- AND IF THOSE PEOPLE
ARE THE RIGHT PEOPLE AND IF
THEY'RE SHARING WITH THEM THE
RIGHT INFORMATION SO FROM A
POLICY STANDPOINT FROM THE
STATE'S LANDS YOU KNOW WHAT
POLICIES CAN WE BEGIN TO THINK
ABOUT. TO KIND OF HELP RESET
THAT PARADIGM.
SO I THINK THAT I THINK THIS
CENTRALLY GOES BACK TO MY MY
THESIS WHICH IS THAT
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE NEEDS
TO BE CONSIDERED AS HEALTH CARE.
AND WHAT WE HAVE DONE OFTEN IS
TO CONSIDER IT AS A SEPARATE
ISSUE AND TALK ABOUT IT
DIFFERENTLY AND THEREFORE WE
CREATES STIGMA WE CREATE
BARRIERS WE INNER INTERACT WITH
THAT OUTSIDE OF THE REST OF THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IN A WAY THAT
INTERFERES WITH ACCESS TO CARE.
AND IN WHICH WE DON'T INTEGRATE
SERVICES FOR ADOLESCENTS FOR
EXAMPLE AS PART OF MY FAMILY
PLANNING SORRY MY FAMILY
MEDICINE PRACTICE I TAKE CARE OF
OF PEOPLE FROM. ZERO TO A
HUNDRED YEARS OLD AND PART OF MY
PRACTICE IS WHEN A PATIENT IS AT
WHERE IT MAY BE TAKEN CARE OF
SINCE THEY WERE BORN COMES IN AT
AGE. TWELVE TO THIRTEEN I ASK
THE PARENT IF I CAN TALK TO THE
PATIENT TO THE TO THE CHILD BY
THEMSELVES AND I HAVE A BLOOD
CONVERSATION WITH THEM.
ABOUT THEIR CONFIDENTIALITY WHAT
RIGHTS THEY HAVE TO TO QUALITY
HEALTHCARE AND ABOUT HOW THEY
CAN ACCESS HEALTH CARE MOVING
FORWARD.
AND I TALK TO THEM BOTH ABOUT
GETTING HEALTH CARE FOR ME BUT
ALSO RECOGNIZING THEY MAY NOT
WANT TO GET HEALTH CARE FOR ME
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
GETTING IT IN THE CONTEXT OF
THEIR FAMILY WHERE THEY CAN GET
HEALTH.
SEPARATELY AND I THINK IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF ME AS A
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE TRANSITIONS OF CARE.
ARE SEAMLESS AND THAT WE ENSURE
THAT ALL PEOPLE HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED I ALSO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THOUGH.
THAT BECAUSE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE IS CONSIDERED SO SEPARATELY
IN OUR SOCIETY WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE OTHER
AVENUES AS YOU REFERENCE FOR
PEOPLE TO GET THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED.
PEOPLE ARE INCREASINGLY LOOKING
FOR INFORMATION ON THE INTERNET.
THROUGH -- MOBILE TECHNOLOGIES
FOR ACCESS TO INFORMATION AND
WAYS THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT
THIS INFORMATION IS CORRECT.
ACCURATE SCIENTIFICALLY ACCURATE
AND AGE APPROPRIATE IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY DOCTOR AT A QUESTION
FOR YOU AND I APOLOGIZE I I CAME
IN A LITTLE BIT LATE SO I MAY
HAVE MISSED IT BUT I WAS
LISTENING TO YOU TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE DISPARITIES IN AWARENESS.
ABOUT REPRODUCTIVE CARE AMONG
ADOLESCENTS AND YOUNG ADULTS AND
JUST DISPARITIES INFORMATION
BETWEEN VARIOUS POPULATIONS.
IF YOU COULD GIVE US A LITTLE
BIT MORE DETAIL JUST HER ABOUT
THE OVERALL LEVEL OF AWARENESS
AMONG ADOLESCENTS AND YOUNG
ADULTS ABOUT REPRODUCTIVE CARE
AND THEN IT IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT YOUR RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
ABOUT WAYS THAT WE CAN RAISE
AWARENESS AMONG.
THE POPULATION GLOBALLY AND
AMONG YOU KNOW FOLKS THAT MAY
NOT POPULATIONS I MAY NOT KNOW
AS MUCH ABOUT.
WHERE THEY CAN ACCESS
REPRODUCTIVE CARRIED ANYTHING
THAT SUGGESTS THAT WE AS POLICY
MAKERS ARE STATE COULD BE DOING
TO HELP RAISE AWARENESS?
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE
GREAT DATA. TO NOTE ACROSS A
POPULATION LEVEL HOW MUCH
ADOLESCENTS AND YOUNG ADULTS
TRULY KNOW ABOUT THE ACCESS TO
ON AND SUBSETS OF THE POPULATION.
SHOW THAT OVERALL THERE'S A
LARGE WAY TO GO FOR US TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY KNOW WHERE TO GO
FOR FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES AND
THAT THEY KNOW THAT THEY CAN
RECEIVE.
THESE SERVICES FOR FREE AND THAT
THEIR CONFIDENTIAL.
AND WE ARE LEADERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE SENSE THAT WE
HAVE VERY PROGRESSIVE
REQUIREMENTS FOR COMPREHENSIVE
SEXUAL HEALTH EDUCATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY YOUTH ACT BUT
THERE IS A LONG WAY TO GO TO
ENSURE.
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
COMPLYING WITH THAT AND
LEGISLATION.
I ALSO WANT TO DRAW ATTENTION TO
THE CUTBACKS THAT WE'VE SEEN AT
THE STATE LEVEL IN PROGRAMS FOR
TEEN PREGNANCY PREVENTION SUCH
AS THE COMMUNITY.
AT C. C. G. THE COMMUNITY
CHALLENGE GRANTS AND MAIL IN.
MAL INVOLVEMENT PROGRAM THESE
PROGRAMS ARE REALLY AND QUITE
POWERFUL FOR GOING OUTSIDE OF
THE SCHOOL SETTING AND IN SOME
CASES INTO THE SCHOOL SETTING TO
HELP MAKE SURE THAT YOUTH WERE
AWARE OF SERVICES.
AND TO LINK THEM AND IN.
WE CALL A WARM HAND OFF WAY IN
SOME CASES ACTUALLY TAKING THEM
TO CLINICS.
MAKING SURE THAT THEY AND SEE
PLAYED OUT HOW THEY WOULD GO
ABOUT ACCESSING CARE SO I'M I
WOULD BE IN FAVOR FOR REVISITING.
STATE FUNDING FOR THOSE PROGRAMS.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
GUESS IS THERE ARE JUST SORT OF
AND YOU KNOW IF THERE'S A WAY
THAT WE CAN ACCESS YOUR RESEARCH
THAT WOULD BE GREAT WE CAN.
TAKE A LOOK AT IT LATER BUT I'M
JUST SORT OF CURIOUS OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD I MEAN.
IS IT 50% AWARENESS AMONG
CERTAIN POPULATIONS THAT YOU
RESEARCHED AS A 20% AWARENESS ME
WHAT A SORT OF THE OVERALL DATA
SHOWING US.
I WOULD BE VERY HAPPY TO SHARE
WITH YOU SOME OF THE
PUBLICATIONS AND I DON'T KNOW
THEM OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD BUT
I WILL GLADLY SEND THEM.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL.
CAN YOU GUYS TELL US ABOUT
WHETHER WE SEEN ANY TO KLEINER
INCREASES IN.
RELATED TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE IN ASKED YOU GUYS BIRTH
CONTROL CANCER WHERE WE GOING IS
A STATE.
SIR WHAT ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE WERE THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS YEAR IS REALLY THE
S. T. I. S. T. D. HIV.
PEPSI CRISIS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ACTUALLY IN IN THAT NOT THAT
MANY PEOPLE SEEM TO BE AWARE OF
WE RANK AMONG THE WORST FOR
SYPHILIS FOR CHLAMYDIA IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY -- AND WE HAD
REQUESTED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO ADD.
AS THE SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS HIV
SPECIFICALLY ANOTHER TWENTY
MILLION TO SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS
HABSI ANOTHER TWENTY MILLION TO
GO AFTER OTHER STDS MESSY EYES.
IN THE BUDGET THIS YEAR AND I
BELIEVE ALL WE WERE AWARDED WAS
ABOUT FIVE MILLION TOTAL TO GO
AFTER THOSE THREE THINGS.
SO -- THIS IS A PRETTY ALARMING
ISSUE.
I SCOTT WINNER HAS A BILL THIS
YEAR THAT WOULD MAKE PREP AND
PERHAPS MUCH MORE AVAILABLE THAT
WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT STEP
TOWARD ADDRESSING HIV CRISIS --
WE HAVE PARTY YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
A PREVENTATIVE CURE NOW. TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF HIV IT IS
ABSURD THAT WE ARE MAKING IT
MUCH MORE READILY AVAILABLE.
AND SO WE'RE SUPPORTING THAT
THAT LEGISLATION -- BUT YEAH SO
SPECIFICALLY ON THAT POINT
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE
ON STDS AND ESTAS.
DO YOU HAVE THOUGHTS ON HOW I
MEAN THOSE.
CHOOSE IF YOU JUST MENTIONED ARE
QUITE ALARMING AND YOU ALSO
MENTIONED SENATOR WIENER
SPELLING FUNDING ARE THERE OTHER
THINGS WE SHOULD BE DOING TO
ADDRESS THAT CRISIS IN OUR STATE.
A LOT OF IT I THINK HAS TO DO
WITH -- YOU KNOW DURING THE
RECESSION PROGRAMS WERE CUT
SIGNIFICANTLY WE HAVE NOT COME
BACK.
TO RE EVALUATE WHERE THE FUNDING
IS FOR THOSE PROGRAMS THAT IS
MUCH OF THE REASON WHY WE'RE
ASKING FOR A TOTAL OF SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS PACKAGE
AND THAT WAS.
A SIGNIFICANT COALITION OF THE
REPRODUCTIVE.
RE AND RIGHTS AND JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WOULD SPUR
SIGNED ON TO THAT -- TO THAT
BUDGET PROPOSAL.
SO -- YEAH I MEAN I I'M NOT NAY
REAL IS NOT THE LEAD ON S. T. S.
T. I WORK BUT I'M.
BUT WE A TON OF INFORMATION I'M
HAPPY TO SHARE WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU WHAT OTHER ANY OTHER
ANY OTHER TRENDS WERE SING IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS IT RELATES.
TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
ARE WE SPOKE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOW MANY COUNTIES DON'T HAVE
ABORTION CLINICS FOR EXAMPLE OF
WHAT DIRECTION ARE WE GOING AND
I WE KNOW THE CURRENT STATE OF
THINGS IS THAT.
MATT HEY WE GOT IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION CAN YOU GUYS GIVE US
SOME INSIGHT WHAT YOU SEEN.
I CAN SPEAK IN TERMS OF TRENDS
IN ACCESS AND USE OF
CONTRACEPTION AND OVERALL AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN USE OF LONG ACTING
REVERSIBLE CONTRACEPTIVE METHODS
IN.
AN IMPLANT BUT OVERALL THERE'S
BàN AND THE RATES OF USE OF ANY
CONTRACEPTIVE METHOD HAVE
REMAINED STABLE.
SO IT'S A AND IT'S A LITTLE
PUZZLING THAT WITH THE WITH THE
GENEROUS AND STATE PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE AN INCREASES IN
INSURANCE Y. L. WHY WE'RE NOT
SEEING A BIGGER.
AND SEEING ANY INCREASE AND
CONTRACEPTIVE USE IN GENERAL.
I'M I ALSO IS I MEAN IT WAS.
SO INTERESTING TO HEAR ABOUT THE
IMPLICIT BIAS NOT JUST IN --
KAREN CHILDBIRTH BUT ALSO IN AND
BIRTH CONTROL AND I WITH THAT
LANDS I HAVE NOT LOOKED AT
SENATOR MITCHELL'S BILL BUT I
HOPE IT ADDRESSES SORT OF THE
IMPLICIT BIAS IN CARE FOR WOMEN
FROM.
CRADLE TO GRAVE BECAUSE IT TURNS
OUT THERE'S A HUGE ISSUE IN THE
WHERE PROVIDING CARE TO WOMEN OF
COLOR -- SO THANK YOU.
FOR SHEDDING LIGHT ON THAT ISSUE --
SO.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
COMING IN FOR HELPING US.
SET THE STAGE ON THE ISSUES AND
MEMBERSHIP.
SO I'VE HI MOM.
IT WAS STRUCK BY SOME OF THE
COMMENTS AROUND THE INCORRECT
RICE'S AROUND STD RATES AND THIS
PAST YEAR THE BUDGET CYCLE I
ALSO HAD -- A SPECIFIC BUDGET
REQUESTS AROUND SOME OF THESE
ISSUES THAT DID NOT GET MATT --
AND THE FACT IS OUR STD RATES
ARE AT A TWENTY FIVE YEAR HIGH --
WE LEAD THE NATION AND GONORRHEA
CHLAMYDIA.
LA LEADS THE STATE IN BOTH --
ALTHOUGH THAT'S NOT A WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF BABIES
BORN WITH SYPHILIS EVERY YEAR.
WITH THESE NUMBERS ARE
ASTRONOMICAL AND ARE NOT REALLY
BEINGDISCUSSED -- PUBLICLY
COULD YOU TALK A BIT MORE YOU
KIND OF ALLUDED TO THIS BUT WHAT
DO YOU SEE AS THE REASONS I
THINK WE ALL DO BELIEVE THAT
INVESTMENT.
OF BUDGET DOLLARS IS CRITICAL
BUT IT SO MUCH THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CONVERSATION IS IS
FOCUSED ON ABORTION AND THE PRO
CHOICE FIGHT BUT THERE IS A
BROADER CONTEXT HERE THAT --
THAT I THINK WE NEED TO TACKLE
WONDERING IF YOU COULD GIVE SOME
FEEDBACK ON THAT.
SORT OF FOLLOW UP ON THAT IN THE
COMMENT ABOUT IMPLICIT BIAS I I
WANNA MAKE THE POINT THAT I
THINK THAT RESPECTFUL CARE IN
THE CONTEXT OF WOMEN WHO ARE NOT
PREGNANT IS ACTUALLY MANY TIMES
EVEN A BIGGER CONCERN.
BECAUSE THESE ARE WOMEN WHO ARE
TRYING NOT TO BE PREGNANT AND
THAT COMES WITH A SET OF
SOCIETAL STIGMA AND JUDGMENT
WOMEN WHO ARE SEXUALLY ACTIVE
BUT DO NOT WANT TO BE PREGNANT.
AND SO THERE ARE ISSUES WITH
RESPECTFUL CARE IN THAT CONTEXT
AND SPECIFICALLY DIFFERENTIAL
RESPECTIVE -- DISRESPECT TOWARDS
WOMEN OF COLOR THAT I THINK
ABSOLUTELY IMPACTS BOTH USE OF
CONTRACEPTION AND USE OF
SERVICES RELATED TO SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS SCREENING
TESTING AND TREATMENT.
AND SO I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
BE PAYING ATTENTION TO THAT IS
NOT MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
CURRENT BILL DOES ADDRESS IT IN
THE FAMILY PLANNING CONTEXT --
STAYS BY MY COLLEAGUE DR NEW
GOMEZ AT BERKELEY HAS FOUND THAT
WOMEN WHO EXPERIENCES RESPECTFUL
CARE IN THE FAMILY PLANNING
CONTEXT ARE LESS LIKELY TO COME
BACK FOR CARE IN THE FUTURE.
AND SO I THINK THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
PAYING MORE ATTENTION TO AS A
WAY TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE CAN
GET THE CARE THAT THEY NEED WHEN
THEY NEED IT WITH RESPECT EVERY
FOR CONTRACEPTION.
ABORTION BUT AUTHORED ALSO WITH
RESPECT TO SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTIONS AND I WOULD ALSO ADD
THAT WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
DISPARITIES IN FOR TWO WILL
INFERTILITY RATES IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THAT WOMEN OF COLOR ARE MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE TO
INFERTILITY RELATED TO THEIR
HIGHER LATE RATES OF SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS AND THE
SAME WOMEN HAVE LESS ACCESS TO
INFERTILITY SERVICES BECAUSE OF
FINANCIAL BARRIERS AND THAT IS A
AN ISSUE THAT IS.
CORD TO REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
RELATED TO WOMEN'S ABILITY TO
HAVE THE CHILDREN THAT THEY WANT
SO WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT BOTH
ADDRESSING THE CRISIS BUT ALSO
ADDRESSING THE IMPLICATIONS FOR
WOMEN'S ABILITY TO HAVE THE
FAMILIES THAT THEY WALKED.
THANK YEAR NOW AND I THINK YOU
HEADED HOME WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE AND BODILY
AUTONOMY BEING BOTH THE RIGHT TO
CHOOSE.
TO HAVE A BABY AND NOT SO I
THINK THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT.
IN A NIGHT.
I DO I WOULD JUST ADD I MEAN
THAT'S WHY RIGHT WE HAVE
ENSHRINED IN OUR REPORT TO
PRIVACY ACT THE RIGHT.
TO OBTAIN ABORTION AS WELL AS
THE RIGHT TO BEAR HEALTHY
CHILDREN I THINK THAT.
WE FOCUS ON THE RIGHT TO TEN
ABORTION BECAUSE IT IS SO
CONSTANTLY UNDER ATTACK AND FOR
NAY ROUTE WE ARE KNOWN AS THE
ABORTION RIGHTS ORGANIZATION.
BUT WE ALSO WORK ON THE FULL
SPECTRUM OF REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
AND REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM TRULY
MEANS HAVING.
CHOICE IN ALL IN ALL WAYS RIGHT
THE CHOICE TO BEAR HEALTHY
CHILDREN WHICH MEANS AN ACTIVE
TRACY ARE NOT DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST IN YOUR WORKPLACE.
BECAUSE YOU ARE PREGNANT BUT YOU
HAVE ACCESS TO PAY FAMILY LEAVE
AND SO I THINK THAT.
AND THEY THE FORCED -- YOU KNOW
THE FOR STERILIZATION ISSUE OF
COURSE ISN'T A WOMAN CARILLO.
HAS A BILL ON THIS ISSUE THIS
YEAR AND LAST AND WE REALLY
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE ALL OF US
VETTING REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
MEANS ACKNOWLEDGING.
OUR TRANSGRESSIONS FROM THE PAST
AND REALLY PAYING -- RESPECT FOR
THOSE SO I THINK I THINK THAT
THERE IS A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE IN BOTH.
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT REPRODUCTION
IS USED AS A TOOL OF OPPRESSION.
WHETHER THAT IS.
AT IMPOSING SOME A LONG ACTING.
IN CONTRACEPTIVE ON A
CONTRACEPTIVE ON A PERSON OR
FORCING THEM.
TO CARRY A PREGNANCY TO TERM
EITHER IS A FORM OF OPPRESSION
AND WE HAVE TO REALLY BE ACTIVE
ON ALL SIDES OF THIS TO ENSURE
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM.
THANK YOU AND I WANNA THANK ALL
OF YOU FOR BEING HERE FOR
SHARING YOUR IMPORTANT INSIGHTS
ON THIS ISSUE AND I HOPE THIS
ISN'T.
THE END OF THE CONVERSATION FOR
US THANK YOU AND THEN I I WILL
NO PROBLEM ASSEMBLYMEMBER COM
LONGER DAD ISN'T READY FOR YOU
TO LEAVE.
I KNOW THAT WHAT HAPPENS IN TWO
BUT I JUST WANTED -- TO KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY DATA ON THE MAKE UP
OF THOSE HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
THAT ARE PROVIDING REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE -- BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WOMEN
OF COLOR.
WE'RE ALSO SORT OF TALKING ABOUT
WHO THE FOLKS ARE THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO SEE -- WHO ARE OFFERING
THEM CARE WHO ARE OFFERING THEM
INFORMATION IN WAYS THAT THEY
CAN RESPECT AND RECEIVE -- AND
SO DO WE HAVE ANY OF THAT DATA
BECAUSE I I THINK THAT SORT OF
DRIVES -- A LARGE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION.
SO WE HAVE A DIVERSITY PROBLEM
IN ALL ASPECTS OF THE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONS WORKFORCE IN THE
FAMILY PLANNING HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM IS NO DIFERENT
THEIR HUGE DIFFERENCE THERE ARE
HUGE PROBLEMS WITH THIS.
AND IN GENERAL IN THE HEALTH
COMMUNICATIONS LITERATURE WHAT
WE KNOW IS THAT RECEIVING RACE
CONCORDANT HEALTH CARE IS
ASSOCIATED WITH GREATER RESPECT
GREATER -- PATIENTS CENTEREDNESS
AND IMPROVE QUALITY OF
EXPERIENCE OF THE INDIVIDUAL
RECEIVING THE CARE SO WE
ABSOLUTELY SHOULD BE INVESTING
IN A MORE DIVERSE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONS WORK FORCE AND WHILE
THAT IS OFTEN A REALLY LONG TERM
QUESTION.
IN THE FAMILY PLANNING SETTING
WHERE MANY PEOPLE ARE MANY
PEOPLE PROVIDING FOR EXAMPLE
CONTRACEPTIVE COUNSELING ARE
UNLICENSED PROVIDERS WHO ARE
HEALTH EDUCATORS I THINK WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST IN
ENSURING THAT THOSE PEOPLE.
ARE MORE DIVERSE MORE REFLECTIVE
OF THE COMMUNICATIONS THAT OF
THE POPULATIONS THAT THEY SERVE --
AND WE ARE CURRENT I'M CURRENTLY
WORKING ON A PROJECT IN
WASHINGTON DC TO ACTUALLY TEST
WETHER RACE CONCORDANT PARA
PROFESSIONALS PROVIDING
CONTRACEPTIVE COUNSELING LEADS
TO IMPROVE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND PATIENT EXPERIENCE
OUTCOMES.
BASED ON THIS VERY STRONG HEALTH
COMMUNICATIONS DATA THAT SHOWS
THAT THAT IS SOMETHING WE SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY BE INVESTING IN.
BECAUSE THAT WILL AFFECT THE
IMMEDIATE EXPERIENCE OF CARE
ESPECIALLY FOR WOMEN OF COLOR
BUT ALSO LONG TERM REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES INCLUDING
MATERNITY CARE OUTCOMES BECAUSE
IF YOU HAVE A POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE.
WITH CONTRACEPTIVE PROVIDER
YOU'RE GOING TO BE MORE LIKELY
TO COME IN EARLIER FOR PRENATAL
CARE TO TO BE TO BE -- TO BE --
CONSISTENT WITH YOUR VISITS AND
TO GET THE CARE THAT YOU NEED.
AND I HOPE YOU'LL KEEP US POSTED
ON THAT RESEARCH ISSUE.
SOME OF THE FINDINGS INTERESTING
WORK SO THANK YOU ALL WE WILL
SWITCH TO THE SECOND PANEL WHICH
IS OUR PANEL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE SERVICES THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR BEING HERE
.
HOW CAN COME ON UP AND JOIN US
AND HOPEFULLY OUR NAMES ARE ON
BOTH SIDES SO YOU CAN SEE MAKE
SURE YOU
?
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US --
OUR SECOND PANEL WHICH IS ON
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WE HAVE MICHELLE
SEMANSKY THE DIRECTOR OF SAFETY
AND SECURITY FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD MY MONTE -- WE HAVE.
STACEY CROSS WHO IS THE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD MARMONT T. C. E. O..
WE HAVE -- WARREN BROUGH DEAN'S
CEO OF EISNER HEALTH.
AND TO RAY VANDER WORTH THAT
PATIENT ADVOCATE WITH HERE TODAY
SO I CAN WILL TURN IT OVER TO
YOU TO NOON AT OPENING AND
INTRODUCE YOURSELF THANK YOU.
A START -- FIRST FLOOR THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW EXCITED I
AM THAT YOU HAVE THIS COMMITTEE
AND THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
BE A BEACON AND LIKE A BEACON OF
LIGHT FOR ALL OF THE COUNTRY
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
SO I'M REPRESENTING THE SEVEN
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
LEADING PROVIDERS OF QUALITY.
AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE AND THE
NATION'S LARGEST PROVIDER.
OF SEXUAL EDUCATION PLANNED
PARENTHOOD HEALTH CENTERS OFFER
COMPASSIONATE CARE BACKED UP BY
MEDICAL RESEARCH AND EXPERTS FOR
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS OF HEALTH
CARE.
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS
HEALTH CARE AND HEALTH CARE IS A
HUMAN RIGHT.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD SERVICES
INCLUDE BIRTH CONTROL CANCER
SCREENING STI TESTING AND
TREATMENT AND ABORTION.
AND THEY ARE ALL CRITICAL IN
ORDER TO HELP US PROVIDE PROTECT
AND EXPAND HEALTHCARE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
IN CALIFORNIA THIS MEANS
DELIVERING HEALTH CARE TO MEET
THE URGENT AN UNMET NEEDS.
OF OUR PATIENTS EXPANDING ACCESS
TO UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
INVESTING IN THE CAPACITY FOR
THE FUTURE.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD OPERATES A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN HEALTH
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
SATELLITE CLINICS AND THEY SPAN
FROM THE NORTHWEST CORNER OF THE
STATE IN EUREKA TO THE SOUTH
WEST CORNER.
NEAR THE MEXICO BORDER IN EL
CENTRO HEALTH CENTERS CAN BE
FOUND IN OUR MAJOR CITIES
THERE'S TWENTY FIVE IN LA IS YOU
KNOW.
THEY WE HAVE HEALTH CENTERS AND
SAN DIEGO SAN JOSE SAN FRANCISCO
OAKLAND.
AND SACRAMENTO AND THROUGHOUT
OUR RURAL AREAS.
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES SERVED AT LEAST SEVEN
HUNDRED AND OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND PATIENTS SEVEN HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THOUSAND PATIENTS.
90% OF WHO WERE AT OR BELOW
2100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LINE. ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
PATIENT VISITS WHICH IS MORE
THAN ANY OTHER STATE IN THE
COUNTRY PLANNED PARENTHOOD
HEALTH CENTERS PROVIDES HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF ESSENTIAL HEALTH
SERVICES SUCH AS SEVENTY TWO
THOUSAND CERVICAL CANCER
SCREENINGS ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION TESTS AND TREATMENT OF
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS.
WE ALSO PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE
SEX EDUCATION IN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE SAW A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS YEAR ESPECIALLY IN THE
LIGHT OF THE FEDERAL ATTACKS
UPON SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE WE HAVE LED AN
EFFORT TO RE ENTER VALUES.
ARE EFFORTS TO DELIVER HEALTH
CARE TO MEET THE URGENT AND
UNMET NEEDS OF OUR PATIENTS.
THIS MEANT REACHING MORE
PATIENTS AND ADDRESSING AND
EMPHASIZING AND FOCUSING ON THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
AS A RELATE TO BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CHILD DEVELOPMENT AND MATERNAL
HEALTH.
WE IDENTIFIED AND CONTINUE TO
WORK TO ADDRESS BARRIERS TO CARE
AND MEET PATIENTS WHERE THEY ARE
APT.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KADI PEACHTREE.
NORRIS ON A. B. TWELVE SIXTY
FOUR TO EXPAND I PROBABLY
PRONOUNCE THAT WRONG I'M SORRY
TO EXPAND HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
OTHER ESSENTIAL REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
VIA VIRTUAL CARE WE ALSO
CONTINUE AND INNOVATE AROUND HOW
TO IMPROVE PATIENT SAFETY BY
INCREASING SECURITY MEASURES.
AROUND AND WITHIN OUR HEALTH
CENTERS.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE CONTINUE TO
STRENGTHEN OUR COMMITMENT BY
EXPANDING HEALTH CARE ACCESS FOR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
BY EXPANDING THE TYPE OF
SERVICES IN AREAS OF NEED WE ARE
EXPANDING TRANCE CARE ACROSS ALL
OF OUR AFFILIATES IN INCREASING
HEALTH CARE ACCESS IN RURAL
AREAS.
STRENGTHENING AND DEVELOPING STI
PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS THE STATE
WIDE EPIDEMIC AND WE ARE
ACTUALLY WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH ALL OF THE
SEVEN AFFILIATES TO REALLY
ADDRESS THE SYPHILIS EPIDEMIC.
AND ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
OPENING FIVE NEW HEALTH CENTERS
ACROSS THE STATE.
AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD MORE MANTE
THE LARGEST PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATE IN THE COUNTRY WE
CURRENTLY ARE WORKING TO MEET
THE UNMET NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S
FROM THE EAST BAY TO BAKERSFIELD.
WE DO THIS WE HAVE OF OUR THIRTY
FIVE HEALTH CENTERS ELEVEN
PROVIDE FULL PRIMARY CARE WE ARE
CONTINUING TO INCREASE OUR
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SPECIALISTS IN
OUR HEALTH CENTERS.
WERE INCORPORATING SERVICES THAT
ADDRESS THE SOCIAL IT
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
ESPECIALLY AS THEY RELATE. TO
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING IN
SECURITIES BECAUSE WE BELIEVE WE
ARE AT A HUMAN RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION AND WE TAKE CARE OF
ALL ASPECTS OF THE PATIENTS.
THAT WALK THROUGH OUR DOORS.
ADVANCING MEDICATION ABORTION
ACCESS AND RURAL COUNTIES LIKE
KERN COUNTY WE PROVIDE.
AND PREP AT ALL OF THEM ARE
MONTY HEALTH CENTERS WHICH HELP
PREVENT HIV AND IT'S PROVIDED AT
EVERY PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE INVESTING IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF COMPREHENSIVE
SEXUAL HEALTH BY ESTABLISHING
FEE FOR SERVICE PROGRAMS.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD VERMONT TAKE ALONG
WITH THE SIX OTHER PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES AND
CALIFORNIA.
IS TO COMMITTED TO ACTIVELY
MEETING THE UNMET NEEDS OF ALL
OF OUR PATIENTS.
AS PLANNED PARENTHOOD CONTINUES
TO FIGHT BACK FIGHT BACK AGAINST
THOSE WHO TAKE OUR COUNTRY
BACKWARDS REAFFIRM OUR
COMMITMENT. TO BREAK DOWN THESE
BARRIERS TO CARE PROVIDING
EXPERT.
HIGH QUALITY AND COMPASSIONATE
CARE TO EVERYONE WHO COMES
THROUGH OUR DOORS NO MATTER WHAT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I DON'T KNOW IF
SOMEBODY WANTS TO HAVE A WOULD
YOU LIKE CONNECTS -- I'M I'M A
LITTLE NERVOUS OLD MYTHS IS MY
FIRST TIME DOING THIS -- IN
FRANCE THANK YOU -- SO GROWING
UP IN CALIFORNIA I WAS THE LAST
PERSON IN MY GROUP OF FRIENDS
AND MY FAMILY TO START MY PERIOD
I WAS.
SIXTEEN YOU KNOW I WAS REALLY
LUCKY ADAM ON WHO'S REALLY OPEN
SHE TALKED TO ME ABOUT WHAT TO
EXPECT MY LITTLE SISTER HAD
ALREADY STARTED SO I KINDA LIKE
KNEW WHAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
BUT MINE WAS NOT NORMAL -- I
KNEW THAT I WAS NOT NORMAL WHEN
MY FIRST LASTED ALMOST SIX WEEKS --
I WAS VOMITING MOST OF THE DAYS
THAT THAT HAPPENED -- I WAS
REALLY LOOKING AT A LOT TEACHERS
RIVER SUPPORT OF IN WHICH LIKE
LET ME SNEAK OUT KNOWN WOULD
QUESTION IT.
BUT YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN YOU'RE
SICK FOR THAT MUCH OR I WOULDN'T
KNOW WHEN MY PERIOD WOULD COME
IT WOULD JUST RANDOMLY HAPPEN --
I DID GET LOTS OF OVER THE
COUNTER MEDICINE TO HELP WITH
THAT BUT THAT JUST WASN'T.
ENOUGH -- SO MY PARENTS AND I
STARTED FIGHTING PRETTY QUICKLY.
FOR ME TO GET BIRTH CONTROL EVEN
THOUGH I WASN'T SEXUALLY ACTIVE
UP BUT I NEEDED IT TO MAKE MY
LIFE A SURVIVOR WILL.
AND WE TRIED LITERALLY YOU NAME
A BIRTH CONTROL EXCEPT FOR LIKE
BOTH THE BAR IN THE ARM I'VE
TRIED IT.
AND NONE OF THEM WERE WORKING --
THEY KEPT FIGHTING BACK
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF MY AGE
LIKE.
BY BY THE TIME I WAS EIGHTEEN
THEY'RE STILL COOL YOU'RE AN
ADULT BUT YOU DON'T REALLY GET
TO CHOOSE LIKE WE DON'T THINK
THAT WHEN SAFE YOU HAVEN'T HAD
KIDS YOU MIGHT WANT TO CHANGE
YOUR MIND -- BUT IT MADE IT
REALLY HARD FOR ME WHILE IN
COLLEGE THINGS GOT A LOT WORSE.
MY DOCTOR STILL REALLY DIDN'T
TAKE INTO THE FACT THAT I WAS
SICK THAT I COULDN'T FUNCTION
THAT THINGS WERE JUST
EMOTIONALLY AND PHYSICALLY IT
GETTING TO THE POINT WHERE I
DIDN'T KNOW HOW I WAS GOING TO
KEEP GOING.
AND I WAS TRYING TO GET MY
BACHELOR'S IN ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY AND I WAS OUT OF STATE --
I WAS ACTUALLY IN MAINE AT THE
TIME EVEN THE GROWING UP HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I IT'S A SCIENCE DEGREE I
HAD FOR OUR LABS AT LEAST ONE TO
TWO A WEEK LIKE I CAN'T MISS
THOSE ARE THINGS MY TEACHERS ARE
GOING TO DRIVE OUT THERE MAKE UP
THOSE LABS -- IN BECAUSE OF MY
ATTENDANCE ME BEING SICK ONE OF
MY PROFESSORS ARE REALLY TRUSTED
WAS REALLY WORRIED ABOUT ME AND
ACTUALLY SUGGESTED THAT I MAYBE
WITHDRAWAL -- BECAUSE OF MY
ABSENCES IN THAT I MIGHT NOT BE
ABLE PASS MY CLASSES BECAUSE
THEY COULDN'T ACCEPT ALL THOSE
ABSENCES -- AND THAT'S NGUYEN
LOCALLY THE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
ON CAMPUS I STARTED WHEN MY
FRIENDS LIKE GO TALK TO THEM SO
I STARTED TALKING TO THEM -- AND
THEY IMMEDIATELY WELL WHY CAN'T
YOU HAVE AN IUD THERE'S NO
REASON FOR YOU AT NINETEEN NOT
TO HAVE AN IUD WE UNDERSTAND YOU
HAVEN'T HAD KIDS BUT THAT'S OKAY --
BUT BECAUSE I WAS ON MY PARENTS
INSURANCE THEY STARTED FIGHTING
WITH THAT INSURANCE COMPANY
SPECIFICALLY TO HELP CONVINCE
THE DOCTORS TO GIVE IT TO ME --
AND EVENTUALLY THEY WERE ABLE TO
GET IT FOR ME I WAS ABLE TO GET
IT THROUGH THEM ACTUALLY INSTEAD
OF THROUGH MY INSURANCE AND
BECAUSE OF THAT.
I KNOW HAVE A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
THE FIRST PERSON MY FAMILY EVER
TO GET A GRADUATE DEGREE AND THE
STATE'S SCIENTISTS I'M ABLE TO
DO WORK I LOVE EVERY DAY.
AND HONESTLY I WOULDN'T BE HERE
TALKING ABOUT THIS IF IT WASN'T
FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD I THINK
MAKING SURE WE HAVE THAT ACCESS
AND THE OTHERS ARE.
AS LUCKY AS ME TO GET THAT
ACCESS IS SO IMPORTANT
THANK YOU MISTER LANDER FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY APPRECIATE IT
AND YOUR BRAVERY.
IT'S NOT EASY TO COME HERE AND
SHARE PERSONAL STORY.
MR ROUTINE WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF IT'S AN HONOR TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY PERCENT TWO YEAR
TODAY.
MY NAME IS WARREN ROUTINE I'M
THE PRESIDENCY OF EISNER HEALTH
OF FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTER IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND WE'RE ONE OF THE NETWORK OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
COLLECTIVELY SERVE SOME SEVEN
MILLION UNIQUE INDIVIDUALS FROM
THE TOP OF THE STATE TO THE
BOTTOM OF THE STATE IN THE OCEAN
TO THE DESERT.
EISNER HEALTH OPERATES TWENTY
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT LA COUNTY
THAT DELIVER COMPREHENSIVE
PRIMARY PREVENTIVE CARE DENTAL
CARE OBSTETRICAL CARE VISION
DERMATOLOGY AS WELL AS
COMPREHENSIVE FAMILY PLANNING TO
SOME FIFTY THOUSAND UNIQUE
INDIVIDUALS.
AND WE DO JUST ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND VISITS ANNUALLY.
THESE FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES
WHICH I'LL TALK ABOUT A LITTLE
BIT I'M TRULY ARE COMPREHENSIVE
AND DELIVERED IN A VARIETY OF
SETTINGS.
I'M ALSO PROUD CONSTITUENT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COUNTY -- SO
THANK YOU FOR REPRESENTING ME --
IT'S IT'S GLAD I'M THRILLED TO
SEE MY REPRESENTATIVE
PARTICIPATING IN THIS TYPE OF
BATTLE AND THAT MAKES ME VERY
PROUD TO BE A RESIDENT F THE
FIFTY FIRST.
I'M FINALLY I'M A FORMER BOARD
MEMBER AND CHAIR OF THE NATIONAL
FAMILY PLANNING AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH ASSOCIATION I'M WHERE I
PARTICULARLY HELPED WORK ON THE
INTEGRATION OF PRIMARY AND
PREVENTIVE HEALTH CARE WITH
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE. FOR
THIS HEARING YOU'VE PROVIDED A
GREAT LIST OF QUESTIONS WELL
ATTEMPT TO GO THROUGH SOME OF
THOSE AREAS REALLY QUICKLY WITH
YOU -- SOME AREAS IN THE VARIOUS
FUNDING AND PROGRAMS THAT YOU
ASKED US TO ADDRESS THAT ARE
HELPFUL.
F. PACKED THE FAMILY PACK
PROGRAM WHICH SUPPORTS -- PEOPLE
WHO DON'T HAVE OTHER MEANS OF
PAYING FOR THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE IS A CRITICAL SOURCE
OF FUNDING FOR THE COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS AND FOR EISNER
HEALTH SPECIFICALLY.
I'M IT'S ALSO VERY IMPORTANT AS
WE EXTEND CONFIDENTIAL SERVICES
TO TEENAGERS -- IN OUR SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS THAT
PROVIDE FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES
IT ALSO WAS A GREAT WAY I'M IN
WHICH WERE ABLE TO EXTEND CARE
TO UNDOCUMENTED WOMEN.
PRIVATE FUNDERS ARE ALSO VERY
ACTIVE IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR
PATIENTS -- YOUR RESPECTIVE OF
WHAT THEIR CHOICES ARE SO WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH.
A NUMBER OF FOUNDATIONS AND
FUNDERS THAT HELP US NOT ONLY
PROVIDE CONTRACEPTION AND AND A
REPRODUCTIVE CARE IN THAT VEIN
BUT ALSO PREPARE WOMEN WHO
CHOOSE TO HAVE CHILDREN AND
PREPARE THEIR FAMILIES -- TO
WELCOME CHILDREN IN LAST YEAR
ISTER HEALTH DELIVERED ABOUT
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED BABIES I'M IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY MAKING ONE OF
MAKING US ONE OF THE LARGEST
OBSTETRICAL PRACTICES WITHIN THE
COUNTY.
DEMAND FOR HEALTH CARE OF ALL
TYPES IS NOT WINNING AT ALL
ESPECIALLY IN LA COUNTY OR
ACROSS LAWS IN ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
DEMAND SIMPLY OUTPACES SUPPLY AT
EVERY TURN.
WE WE RELY ON PROGRAMS LIKE F.
PACKED AND THE MEDI CAL
EXPANSION.
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THE BASELINE
REIMBURSEMENT TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE THE PATIENTS WHO COME AND
PRESENT FOR CARE WITH US.
IN THE AFTER PACKED
REIMBURSEMENT SPACE.
IN THE PAST THERE'S BEEN SORT OF
THIS PEAK AND VALLEY AND CHANGES
IN THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE AND
INSTABILITY -- WHERE LATER IN
THE YEAR WE RECEIVE NOTIFICATION
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE A
CHANGE IN THE OF PACKED
REIMBURSEMENT RATE?
AND THE LACK OF STABILITY WITHIN
THAT -- REIMBURSEMENT MECHANISM
PREVENTS US FROM EXPANDING
FURTHER AND MAKING PLANS IN A IN
A SECURE WAY KNOWING THAT THE
REIMBURSEMENT MAY RISE OR FALL
DEPENDING ON THE POINT OF THE
YEAR. FOR THOSE WHO ARE SEEKING
THE CONFIDENTIAL CARE COST AN
ACCESS REMAIN A CRITICAL ISSUE
FOR THEM TO OVERCOME.
PARTICULARLY FOR TEENAGERS WERE
SEEKING CONFIDENTIAL SERVICES
WITHIN OUR SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS AND FOR THOSE WHO DON'T
HAVE INSURANCE LIKE THE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION.
THERE'S ALSO -- WHEN I CALLED
THE FORGOTTEN MIDDLE THE GROUP
OF PEOPLE WHO EARN JUST A LITTLE
BIT TOO MUCH TO QUALIFY FOR
MEDICARE ALL -- BUT NOT ENOUGH
TO REALLY BE ABLE TO PAY FOR
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH INSURANCE
WITHIN THEIR FAMILIES A MAN WHO.
AT AND UP FORGO WEIGHING
COVERAGE EVEN THOUGH IT'S
AVAILABLE ON THE EXCHANGE FOR
THEM.
I'M SO THE F. PACKED PROGRAM
STEPS IN FOR A NUMBER OF THOSE
FOLKS WHO POP JUST OVER THE
FEDERAL POVERTY GUIDELINES LINE
AND ALLOWS US TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS THIS CRITICAL CARE IS
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
ISER IS DOING SOME REALLY
INNOVATIVE THINGS WE THANK -- IN
ORDER TO EXTEND THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE TO EVERYBODY.
NOTABLY IT'S COMPLETELY
INTEGRATED INTO OUR PRIMARY CARE
PRACTICE SO WE RUN ALL OF OUR
PROVIDERS AND OUR STAFF GO
THROUGH EDUCATION AND TRAINING
SPECIFICALLY ON HOW TO INTEGRATE
SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
INTO THE PRIMARY CARE MODEL AND
THE FOLKS IN THE PREVIOUS PANEL
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES AS
WELL -- THE EXPANSION OF THE
FAMILY PLANNING INTO THE HIGH
SCHOOL SETTING -- AS WELL AS IN
CHIU EVEN SOME OF OUR PEDIATRIC
PRACTICES FOR WE HAVE
PEDIATRICIANS WHO ARE HELPING
LEAD THE CHARGE -- AS THEIR
PATIENTS REACH ADOLESCENCE AND
STARTING TO INTEGRATE THE SEXUAL
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH -- QUESTIONS
INTO THEIR HEALTHCARE AS A
DOCTOR DESCRIBING THE EARLIER
PANEL.
IN THE HIGH SCHOOLS WERE DOING
VERY WELL AT INVOLVING PARTNERS --
WITHIN THE CARE AND TREATMENT
MOST NOTABLY FOR S. T. I.
SCREENING AND TREATMENT AS WELL
AS FOR CONTRACEPTION.
AND FINALLY WE'VE IMPLEMENTED
THE ONE KEY QUESTION -- ACROSS
ALL OF OUR PRIDE OUR PRIMARY
CARE SERVICES WHICH IS THE
QUESTION IN WHICH WE ASK THE
VERY SIMPLE QUESTION ARE YOU
PLANNING ON BECOMING PREGNANT
THIS YEAR.
IN THE COMING YEAR -- TO WOMEN
WHO SEE CARE AND WE'RE ALSO
ASKING THE SAME QUESTION OF OUR
MALE PATIENTS TO SEE IF THEY
PLAN ON HAVING CHILDREN AND IN
THE SHORT TERM COMING FORWARD.
CULTURAL COMPETENCE IS WHY OUR
PATIENTS CHOOSE US I'M 78% OF
OUR PATIENTS ARE LATINO LATINA
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE HAVE --
WE HAVE A GROWING ASIAN
POPULATION WITHIN OUR HEALTH
CENTERS AS WELL -- AND THEN IN
OUR AREAS IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY SOME OTHER GROWING
IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS AND WE
SEEK TO OFFER CAREER PATH
EMPLOYMENT -- WITHIN OUR HEALTH
CENTERS.
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES FOR OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS SO THAT THAT
WAY WE REACH THIS CONCORDANCE
BETWEEN -- COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SERVING THEM.
WE TAKE THEIR CULTURAL RELIGIOUS
PREFERENCES OF OUR PATIENTS AND
STAFF INTO ACCOUNT I'M AS
REQUIRED AND ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE TRAINING OUR STAFF TO ASK
CRITICAL QUESTIONS OF THAT WERE
MEETING OUR PATIENTS WHERE THEY
ARE.
IN THEIR OWN LIFE JOURNEY AS FAR
AS THAT'S CONCERNED.
AND FINALLY WE OPERATE AN OLD
NUMBER OF TRAINING PROGRAMS WE
HAVE A FULL SPECTRUM FAMILY
MEDICINE TRAINING PROGRAM UNDER
OUR ROOF -- AND THEN WE ALSO --
WORKED WITH RESIDENTS IN
OBSTETRICS GYNECOLOGY AND
TRAINEES IN NURSE MIDWIFERY SO
THAT TOGETHER -- WE ARE MAKING
SURE THAT THIS CARE IS
COMPLETELY A PART OF THE GENERAL
PRIMARY CARE THAT WE OFFER ALL
CARE IS REGARDLESS OF ABILITY TO
PAY SLIDING FEE SCALES ACCESS TO
THREE FORTY BE PRICED DRUGS.
ARE ALL HALLMARKS OF THE WAY
THAT WERE TEARING DOWN BARRIERS
TO ACCESS TO SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE.
WORKING IN PARTNERING WITH
COUNTLESS COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE LOCAL PLANNED
PARENTHOOD'S -- PREDOMINANTLY AS
WELL AS OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SEEK.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR
PARTICIPANTS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE PRIMARY AND COMPREHENSIVE
CARE THAT THEY THAT THEY NEED
AND THAT THEY DELIVER.
AND DESERVE -- WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF OUR MIDWIFERY MODEL OF CARE
IN THE DELIVERY OF WOMEN'S
HEALTH SERVICES AND DELIVERIES
MOST OF OUR OBSTETRICAL
DELIVERIES ARE PERFORMED BY A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES INTO
HOSPITALS WHICH WE STAFF.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THREE SIXTY
FIVE SO THAT IS AN ABSOLUTE
CORPS OF THE PATIENT CENTERED
MIDWIFERY MODEL THAT WERE SUPER
PROUD OF REGULATORY EARLY AND WE
HAVE WITHIN THE ASSEMBLY.
STABILIZING THE F. PACKED RATES
WOULD BE A GREAT OUTCOME FOR US --
MEDIUM AND LONG TERM CONTINUING
TO SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF
NURSE PRACTITIONER AND CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIFERY TRAINING
PROGRAMS.
I'M IS A GREAT WAY THE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA CAN PARTICIPATE
WITH US -- AND SUPPORTING THE
EXPANSION OF SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS THIS IS A PRIMARY WAY IN
WHICH WE ARE ACCESSING
INDIVIDUALS WHO TRULY NEED
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE.
AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE GROWING A
POPULATION OF SAVVY HEALTHCARE
CONSUMERS AS THEY REACH
ADULTHOOD.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY.
THANK YOU MISS SEMANSKY MY
PLANTS ANYWAY.
THANK YOU -- MY NAME IS MICHELLE
SEMANSKY AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
SAFETY AND SECURITY FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD MARMONT TODAY BUT I
AM ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA AND
ENDS.
I WANTED TO TALK TO A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT TODAY TODAY ABOUT SOME OF
THE THINGS WE FACE IN MY JOB I
DEAL WITH.
THREATS TO OUR PATIENTS OUR
STAFF AND OUR FACILITIES -- THE
PROTESTER RESPONSE HOW WE HANDLE
THE ACTIVE PROTESTERS OUTSIDE.
OF OUR HEALTH CENTERS AND THE
SAFETY TRAINING TO PREPARE FOR
WHATEVER MAY BE COMING.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES WE FACE IS THE
PERCEPTION IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WE'RE FINE THAT WERE NOT FACING
CHALLENGES.
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ACCESS CARE THERE ARE NO
BARRIERS FOR PATIENTS -- OR OUR
STAFF -- AND THAT UNFORTUNATELY
IS NOT TRUE WE SEE PROTESTERS
WEEKLY OUTSIDE OF OUR HEALTH
CENTERS THE NUMBERS ARE GROWING --
AND THAT NUMBER OF DAYS THEY'RE
OUT IN FRONT OF OUR HOUSE
CENTERS ARE GROWING -- WE HAVE
EXPERIENCE VIOLENCE AT OUR
HEALTH CENTERS IN JUSTIN'S SINCE
TWENTY OF THE TWENTY ELEVEN
WE'VE HAD THREE ARE SINCE.
AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD SITES IT
FOR MY MANTEO LOAN -- AND THIS
THESE ARE THINGS WE DO AS ON A
DAILY BASIS WONDERING WHAT.
THE NEXT SHOE WILL DROP AND WHAT
TO EXPECT SO OUR STAFF HAVE TO
DEAL WITH.
PREPARING FOR THE UNIMAGINABLE
AND PREPARING FOR THE UNEXPECTED
AND KEEPING AN EYE OUT DAILY FOR
WHAT MIGHT BE COMING THROUGH THE
DOOR WE CALL IT LOOKING OUT FOR
THE CRAZY -- AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT LEADS TO A HIGH
LEVEL OF ANXIETY AMONG THEIR
STAFF.
IN TERMS OF NOT KNOWING.
WHERE THE NEXT WEIRD THING OR
DANGEROUS THING MIGHT BE COMING
FROM WE DO THE BEST THAT WE CAN
TO PREPARE -- BUT WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THINGS THAT OTHER
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS DON'T WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH BOMB THREATS.
WE HAVE WE PREPARE STAFF TO DEAL
WITH SUSPICIOUS PACKAGES AND
WHAT TO DO OF SOMETHING'S LEFT --
I GET CALLS REGULARLY ABOUT
BACKPACKS LEFT IN WAITING ROOMS
AND NORMALLY THAT'S A SIMPLE
LOST AND FOUND SITUATION THAT
OUR HEALTH CENTERS WE OFTEN HAVE
TO CALL IN THE FBI TO COME.
AND CLEAR THE PACKAGE -- BECAUSE
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN THAT
BACKPACK -- IS SO THERE'S A
LEVEL OF HIGHER CONCERN OF WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN AND BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS
SEEN AS A LIBERAL MECCA IT'S
MAKING OUR HEALTH CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND EVEN STRONGER
FOCUS. FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
PROVE A POINT -- SO WE ARE
SEEING INCREASED A POTESTER
ACTIVITY AT OUR HEALTH CENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA THEY WANT TO MAKE
IT SO OUR PATIENTS CAN'T.
OR DON'T WANT TO SPEAK SERVICES
AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD SO THAT WE
WILL HAVE TO SHUT OUR DOORS.
AND JUST LAST WEEK WE HAD A
PATIENT COME BACK INTO THE
HEALTH CENTER CRYING AT RBC
LOCATION IN SACRAMENTO BECAUSE
SHE FELT THE PROTESTERS WERE
BLOCKING HER FROM GOING TO HER
CAR SHE WAS BEING FOLLOWED TO
HER CAR.
AND TOLD ALL THE REASONS WHY SHE
WAS A BAD PERSON FOR COMING FOR
SERVICES AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
AFTER HER VISIT SHE WAS JUST
TRYING TO GO HOME.
AND SHE CAME BACK IN AND OUR
STAFF WALKED HER TO OUR CARS IS
THAT SHE WOULD FEEL SAFE BECAUSE
SHE HAD TO PARK ON THE STREET ON
THAT DAY BECAUSE IT WAS A DAY
THAT WE USUALLY DON'T HAVE
PROTESTERS.
WE ACTUALLY ASK OUR STAFF TO
PARK ON THE STREET ON THE DAYS
THAT WE HAVE PROTESTERS SO THAT
THEY GET TO WALK THROUGH THE
PROTESTORS AND OUR PATIENTS
DON'T HAVE -- TO BUT THESE ARE
THE THINGS WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
ON A REGULAR BASIS -- ONE OF THE
OTHER.
UNIQUE THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IS.
INCONSISTENT ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS
LOCAL ORDINANCES -- ONE OF OUR
HEALTH CENTERS OF HAVING A
PROBLEM AND IN THE SAN DIEGO
AREA RIGHT NOW.
GETTING TRESPASSED AND FORCE
BECAUSE THE PROTESTERS WANT TO
COME ON THE PROPERTY -- TO
PROTEST AND THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SAYS ITS FIRST
AMENDMENT WE CANNOT FORCE
TRESPASS HERE -- YOU KNOW MOST
OF US WOULD SAY THAT'S NOT
REALLY.
A SITUATION BECAUSE IT'S TRUST
PASS IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING -- BUT THE
SELECTIVE INTERPRETATION OF
LOCAL LAWS -- AND FOR ME I HAVE
THIRTY FIVE HEALTH CENTERS THAT
I'M RESPONSIBLE FOR SO I HAVE TO
KNOW AND UNDERSTAND THE CITY AND
COUNTY ORDINANCES. FOR THIRTY
FIVE LOCATIONS -- AND HOW THEY
WILL BE APPLIED AND BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THE LAWS IS APPLIED EVENLY
AND THESE ARE THINGS THAT ALL OF
THE AFFILIATES ARE DEALING WITH
IN TERMS OF TRYING JUST.
TO TAKE THE POLITICS OUT OF THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING AND JUST
MAKE IT ABOUT ENFORCING A SIMPLE
NO TRESPASS Là OR A SIGN
ORDINANCE Là OR NOISE ORDINANCE
Là.
OR THINGS LIKE THAT THAT SHOULD
BE BLACK AND WHITE BUT BECAUSE
OF THE TOPIC OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ABORTION RIGHTS IT
BECOMES AN ISSUE THAT.
THE PEOPLE HAVE AN OPINION ON
AND THEN THE IT BECOMES
QUESTIONABLE ON WHY THEY'RE
CHOOSING TO ENFORCE OR NOT
CHOOSING TO ENFORCE -- SO THESE
ARE SOME OF THE THINGS.
THAT WE DEAL WITH ON A REGULAR
BASIS AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE AND
PROVIDING YOUR INSIGHT -- YOUR
TEACHING US A LOT I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
HAS A QUESTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- MISS
RUNNING.
YES CONSTITUENTS.
I DON'T THINK TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
BABIES THAT YOUR THAT AYE SIR
HEALTH HELP DELIVER THIS PAST
YEAR DO YOU HAVE AN ESTIMATE AND
AS TO HOW MANY OF THE WOMEN OR
ON MEDI CAL OR ON SOME KIND OF
ASSISTANCE OR IF YOU COULD JUST
SHARED MAYBE SOME OF THOSE.
THE STATISTICS I WANT TO GET AN
IDEA AS TO INCOME -- AND SOCIAL
FOR SHORT THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION -- AND EISNER OF THE
TAKEN ACROSS THE BOARD 75% OF
OUR PATIENTS ARE BELOW A HUNDRED
AND 50% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL.
SO.
BELOW 110050% SO FOR A SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL THAT WOULD BE RIGHT
AROUND EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR IN ANNUAL INCOME.
MORE OR LESS -- AND WITHIN OTHER
DELIVERIES THE VAST MAJORITY ARE
COVERED BY MEDICARE ALL --
EITHER THROUGH A MEDICAID
MANAGED CARE PLAN -- THROUGH A
DIRECT MEDI CAL CONTRACT WITH LA
CARE OR WITH MEDI CAL
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY -- AND
THEN UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE ARE.
COVERED BY PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY A SMALL NUMBER OF
PATIENTS BECAUSE OF OUR UNIQUE
MIDWIFERY MODEL -- A SMALL
NUMBER OF OUR PATIENTS ARE
COMMERCIALLY INSURED AND CHOOSE --
OUR ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE OF THE
MIDWIFERY SERVICE AND BECAUSE OF
THE SPECIAL WRAPAROUND SERVICES
THAT WE PROVIDE TO THOSE WOMEN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. NINE IMAGINE VERY
SIMILAR STATISTICS FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD YEAH I FOR THE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES IN
CALIFORNIA 90% LIVE AT OR BELOW
2100% POVERTY LEVEL WHICH I
THINK IS ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND A
YEAR.
WHICH IS AS WE ALL KNOW IS
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO SUSTAIN
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH OUR HUGE HOMELESS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SITUATION.
WHAT IS THE NATIONAL POVERTY
RATE?
IF YOU HAPPEN TO KNOW I I DON'T
KNOW BUT WE CAN GET THAT
INFORMATION TO YOU.
WE JUST GO I KNOW THAT SINCE
I'VE BEEN -- A CEO IN MULTIPLE
PLAN PARENTS AND AT DIFFERENT
STATES THE VAST MAJORITY OF ALL
OF THAT BABIES DELIVERED IN I
KNOW IN CALIFORNIA OREGON
WASHINGTON AND MONTANA WERE MORE
THAN 50% OF THEM WERE THREE
MEDICAID.
I REPRESENT A DISTRICT THAT IS
DIVIDED BY A FREEWAY THE ONE TEN
FREEWAY.
SO ON ONE SIDE OF THE FREEWAY WE
HAVE HIGHER INCOME -- HIGHER
EDUCATION LEVELS AND ON THE
OTHER SIDE WHICH IS
PREDOMINATELY EAST LA
UNINCORPORATED IT'S 20% BELOW
THE NATIONAL POVERTY LINE.
AND SO THANK YOU FOR THE
SERVICES THAT YOU PROVIDE THE
CONSTITUENTS OF EIGHTY FIFTY ONE
AND REALLY ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- THESE NUMBERS ARE
SHOCKING WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
OR TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR FOR AN ANNUAL SALARY AND
YOU THINK ABOUT THE INCREASE OF
FRIENDS THE INCREASE OF CHILD
CARE.
THE INCREASE OF FOOD OR TO
SUSTAINABILITY IN GENERAL AND
FOR THE FOR FAMILIES THAT ARE
PLANNING ON HAVING CHILDREN OR
IF YOU HAPPEN.
TO HAVE A CHILD AND HOW DO YOU
JUST LIVE YOUR YOUR LIFE -- AS
DISCUSSED IN THE PREVIOUS PANEL.
CHOICES ABOUT.
CHOICE.
BUT ALSO THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE
TO PLAN.
THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY.
CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES THAT YOU'RE
HEALTH CENTERS EXPERIENCE -- IN
PROVIDING.
THIS ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE AND HOW WE AS THE
LEGISLATURE CAN HELP
[inaudible]
INCREASES BARRIERS.
WHAT WE I THINK -- PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IN CALIFORNIA HAS
DONE A GREAT JOB OF INTEGRATING
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AND DE
STIGMATIZING -- ABORTION SO IT'S
JUST PART OF YOU KNOW MOST OF
OUR CENTERS PROVIDE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE IN SOME PROVIDE
PRIMARY CARE.
AND SO WE'VE REALLY DONE A GREAT
JOB WITH THAT OF COURSE FUNDING
HAS HELPED SOME OF THE BARRIERS
TO CARE THAT OUR PATIENTS HAVE.
OF OUR NUMBER ONE REASON FOR NO
SHOW FOR EXAMPLE IN OUR CENTRAL
VALLEY AREA IS TRANSPORTATION.
SO BEING ABLE FOR OUR PATIENTS
TO ACCESS SOME FORM OF
TRANSPORTATION TO GET TO THEIR
HEALTH CENTER IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT -- THAT'S I WOULD SAY
ONE OF MY NUMBER ONE REASONS AND
THEN ALSO HAVING PROVIDERS AT
OUR HEALTH CENTERS THE WHAT HAS
HAPPENED AND THE REIMBURSEMENT
INCREASE HAS REALLY MADE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE. FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
HIDE PROVIDE HIGHER PROVIDERS IF
YOU DON'T HAVE PROVIDERS YOU
CAN'T PROVIDE HEALTH CARE AND
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL AREAS
WHERE IT'S MUCH MORE CHALLENGING.
TO BE ABLE TO HIRE PROVIDERS IT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE WE'VE HAD TO
DO THINGS TO YOU KNOW INCREASE
OUR SALARIES INCREASE OUR BONUS
AND RETENTION.
BUT IT'S REALLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR
PEOPLE TO WORK IN RURAL AREAS IF
THEIR PARTNER DOESN'T HAVE A JOB
AND IF THEY CAN'T FIND HOUSING.
SO THERE'S A VARIETY OF A
BARRIERS AND THAT REALLY LIMITS
THE CARE THAT'S AVAILABLE IF WE
DON'T HAVE A A PROVIDER THAT'S
THERE BUT I WOULD SAY.
TRANSPORTATION IS OUR NUMBER ONE
ISSUE AND GETTING SAFE
TRANSPORTATION BECAUSE WE ARE
LOOKING AT PARTNERING WITH
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE THAT TRANSPORTATION.
BUT OF COURSE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT IT'S SAFE AND
CONFIDENTIAL FOR OUR PATIENTS
THAT ARE GOING TO OUR HEALTH
CENTERS.
CAN I WOULD HAVE TO GO MS
CROSSES COMMENTS OF IT THAT'S
EXACTLY TRANSPORTATION ISN'T
URBAN ISSUE AS WELL -- AND I
DON'T HAVE TO TELL MY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PARKING -- AND THE CITY
IS A MASSIVE ISSUED AT THE CAN A
CASE IN POINT IT SOUNDS TONGUE
IN CHEEK BUT A CASE IN POINT.
WE WILL AT JUST OUR THREE
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES HEALTH
CENTERS IN THE COMING YEAR SPENT
OVER A QUARTER OF A MILLION
DOLLARS IN PARKING FOR OUR
PATIENTS -- IN BEEN PARKING
SUBSIDIES OF NOT TO MENTION EVEN
GOING DOWN THE PATH OF BUS
TOKENS AND OTHER TRANSPORTATION.
ISSUES ANOTHER WAY THE ASSEMBLY
CAN HELP IS CONTINUE TO EXPAND
THE AVAILABILITY OF LOAN
REPAYMENT -- FOR CLINICIANS WHO
ARE COMING ON BOARD AND OTHER
STAFF WERE DEDICATING THEIR
CAREERS TO A LOW INCOME
POPULATION -- PROVIDING THE THE
RETENTION OF FONG THAT YOU'VE
DONE WITH LOAN REPAYMENT IN THE
PAST THAT ALLOWS THE CLINICIANS
TO ACCESS THAT.
WITH WITH PHYSICIANS AND NURSE
PRACTITIONERS MIDWIVES --
DENTISTS IN ALL COMING OUT OF
TRAINING WITH A QUARTER OF A
MILLION DOLLARS OR MORE IN
STUDENT LOAN DEBT COUPLED WITH
THE MEDIAN HOUSING PRICE IN LOS
ANGELES MEANS THAT WE HAVE A
HARD TIME RECRUITING AND
RETAINING -- PROVIDERS LONG TERM
AND IT'S A IT'S A TREMENDOUS
IT'S A TREMENDOUS BARRIER WHEN
YOU THINK THAT A PHYSICIAN CAN'T
CHOOSE TO WORK IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THE FIZZ A PHYSICIAN
CANNOT AFFORD TO RENT AN
APARTMENT NEAR THE OFFICE.
HI I ECHO THAT THE NUMBER ONE
REASON I LOSE PROVIDERS IS LOAN
REPAYMENT -- AND THAT IS THAT IS
HUGE PARTICULAR FOR A MID LEVEL
PROVIDERS WE CAN'T BE
COMPETITIVE.
OUR SOME OF DO YOU SEE THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
RELATED TO THE ISSUES
INVESTMENTS GET TALKED ABOUT.
RELIGIOUS SAFETY AND SECURITY.
CAN YOU SAY THAT AGAIN SO WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUE
WITH RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
OF PROVIDERS RELATED.
TO FINANCING BUT DOES THE SAFETY
AND SECURITY ISSUES THAT YOU'RE
CLINICS FACE AS DESCRIBED BY
MISSING ASKEY ALSO AFFECT
CRIMINAL INTENTION OF PROVIDERS.
OR DO NOT SEE A CONNECTION.
YEAH GO AHEAD AND THEN ALL AT I
KNOW THAT I SPEND A LARGE AMOUNT
OF MY TIME ACTING AS A COUNSELOR
TO OUR STAFF AND A LOT OF WHAT I
DO IS LETTING THEM TALK ABOUT
THE THINGS THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE
TO DEAL WITH.
JUST TO GO TO WORK EVERY DAY --
I HAD ONE OF ONE OF OUR
EDUCATORS WITH MAD BECAUSE HE
HAS TO ASK.
THE THE LARGE NUMBER OF
PROTESTERS INSIDE OF THE HEALTH
CENTER ARE OUTSIDE OF THE HOUSE
CENTER TO MOVE OUT OF THE WAY
JUST TO WALK ON THE SIDEWALK SO
HE CAN GET TO HIS JOB EVERY DAY
AND THAT WEARS ON AND SO.
I I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE COME
TO WORK AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
BECAUSE OF THE MISSION AND THAT
HELPS TO COUNTERACT.
THAT THE FEELING -- BUT THERE
ARE PEOPLE.
ESPECIALLY SOME OF OUR LOWER
LEVEL PROVIDERS ARE HEALTH
SERVICE SPECIALIST MEDICAL
ASSISTANT LEVEL PEOPLE WHO COME
THERE JUST FOR A JOB.
A ONE OF PAY THEIR BILLS AND
THEY WANT A CAREER AND AND THEY
DON'T WANT TO PUT UP.
WITH THE STUFF THAT WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH AND THEY WILL GO -- TO
A HOSPITAL SETTING AT KAISER
SETTING A DOCTOR'S OFFICE
SETTING IF THEY'RE NOT.
IF IT'S NOT COUNTERACTED BY THE
MISSION DR LUCKILY WE HAVE A LOT
OF OUR STAFF WHO REALLY WANT TO
WORK AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
BECAUSE OF THE SERVICES WE
PROVIDE.
AND THE PRIDE THAT WE HAVE IN
OUR WORK SO IT DOES BALANCE BUT
THE I DO KNOW PEOPLE WHO HAVE
LEFT BECAUSE THEY JUST DON'T
WANT TO DEAL WITH HAVING TO WALK
THROUGH PEOPLE SCREAMING AT THEM
EVERY DAY AND NOT KNOWING WHAT'S
COMING NEXT.
YEAH WE GO THROUGH EXTRAORDINARY
MEANS TO PROTECT OUR STAFF AND
OUR PATIENTS AND AND PROTECTING
THEIR PERSONAL PRIVACY I'M
ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT OUR
PROVIDERS PROTECTION AND WE DO
WHAT EVER WE CAN.
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE BECAUSE
WHAT HAPPENS IS PEOPLE CAN
SEARCH AND FIND OUT WHERE THEY
LIVE.
THERE ARE PROVIDERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THAT HAVE HAD PROTESTERS
AT THEIR HOUSE EVERY DAY FOR
OVER THREE YEARS.
FORTUNATELY WE HAVEN'T HAD THAT
EXTREME HERE BUT I DO BELIEVE
WITH WHAT IS HAPPENING IN OUR
NATION WITH THIS REVOLT AGAINST
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AND
FRANKLY.
POOR PEOPLE AND WOMEN I'M AFRAID
THAT THAT'S GOING TO ELEVATE SO
WE REALLY ARE DOING WHATEVER WE
CAN. TO PROTECT OUR STAFF THERE
ARE AMAZING AND THEY PROVIDE
SUCH GREAT CARE TO THE PATIENTS
IN FRONT OF THEM SO ANYTHING
THAT YOU CAN DO. TO HELP US
PROTECT OUR STAFF AND OUR
PATIENTS WOULD BE INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL.
SEVERAL STAFF MEMBERS.
IT IS THE SECOND HOME PROGRAM --
WHICH IS A STATE RUN PROGRAM
THAT IS MEANT TO DEAL. TO
PROVIDE PROTECTIONS FOR WOMEN
WHO ARE IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATIONS BUT HAS BEEN EXPANDED.
TO TO HEALTH.
PEOPLE WHO ARE PROVIDE AT HEALTH
CARE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE
SERVICES OR FEEL THEY'RE UNDER
THREAT BECAUSE OF THAT -- BUT IT
IS A VERY CHALLENGING PROGRAM TO
NAVIGATE -- AND A LOT OF TIMES
WHEN WE REACH OUT AND SAY WE
WOULD LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROGRAM THEY'RE LIKE OH
THAT'S FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ONLY AND THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW
THEIR OWN PROGRAM THAT.
IT HAS BEEN EXPANDED. TO PROVIDE --
FOR YOU KNOW A PO BOX SOTHAT
YOU CAN GET YOUR LEGAL DOCUMENTS
THEIR PO BOX INSTEAD OF A HOME
ADDRESS WHICH IS HARDER TO TRACK
ON THE INTERNET AND THINGS LIKE
THAT -- SO -- WE'VE ACTUALLY
CREATED SOME AND INFORMATION TO
HELP OUR STAFF -- LIKE THE
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS THEY
MIGHT ENCOUNTER FOR IF THEY WANT
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM
AND HELP THEM NAVIGATE HOW TO
ENROLL -- BECAUSE THEY CAN BE
SUCH A CHALLENGING SITUATION FOR
THEM.
HOW DOES THAT AS AS A POINT OF --
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE AND
DISCUSSING THESE ISSUES AND A
HEARING SUCH AS THIS IS THAT
THERE'S NO NEED TO SUGAR COAT IT
THE FACT IS THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
BOMB THREATS THERE HAS BEEN OUR
CENTER HAS BEEN OPENED FIRE THE
PEOPLE A GUNMAN OPENING FIRE AT
A PLANNED PARENTHOOD CLINIC.
THE DANGER IS NOT ONLY TO THE
PATIENTS BUT TO THE STAFF AND
THE MENTAL WELL BEING OF STAFF
FOR RETIREMENT AND RECRUITMENT
TO ENSURE THAT WOMEN CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE ADEQUATE BE ADEQUATE --
COUNSELING AND AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE THAT THEY NEED IS A
REAL ISSUE.
AND SO THESE ARE THINGS THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO BE BOLD AND
UNAPOLOGETIC ABOUT AND THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO REASON. TO TRY TO
CIRCUMVENT THE ACTUALITY OF WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN THE FACT IS THAT.
THERE'S A LOT TO BE A SAID ON
THE NATIONAL LEVEL AND THERE'S A
LOT THE CALICO THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN DO TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
SAFETY -- AT THESE CLINICS AND
THAT THE PATIENTS ARE SAFE AND
THAT.
THE WORKERS ALSO FEEL THAT
THEY'RE PROTECTED.
THANK YOU ARE STAFF OUR HEROES
PROVIDING THIS CARE PROVIDING
BASIC HEALTHCARE FOR OUR
FAMILIES COMMUNITY SO THANK YOU.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR ALL THE DATA
PROVIDER PACKED OF HEALTH CARE
AND HEALTH CARE CALIFORNIANS.
I'M SO WE TAUGHT YOU MENTIONED --
MISTER DEAN.
AT SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS
AM I WANT TO TALK ABOUT IF THERE
ANY OTHER INNOVATIVE PRACTICES.
THE ORGANIZATIONS ARE PURSUING
TO ADDRESS THE UNMET NEEDS THEY
WERE SITTING IN CALIFORNIA.
YEAH I THINK IT'S EASY TO SAY
THAT THAT WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS
WE DO WHATEVER WE CAN WE MEET
OUR PATIENTS WHERE THEY ARE AND
WE HAVE A VERY DEDICATED.
TALENTED CULTURALLY COMPETENT
STAFF THAT WORKED REALLY CLOSELY
WITH INDIVIDUAL PATIENTS TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY NEED -- ONE
ONE EXAMPLE -- WOULD BE -- WE
PARTNER WITH A VARIETY OF
ORGANIZATIONS AND WITHIN THE
DELIVERY CARE THAT WE PROVIDE WE
WORK WITH -- ALL COMERS SO IF A
WOMAN HAS DECIDED TO HAVE A BABY
WE'RE GOING TO PARTNER WITH THE
PRENATAL SETTING IN WHICH SHE'S
RECEIVED IF SHE'S GOING TO
DELIVER UNDER OUR ROOF.
SO NOT ALL OF OUR PATIENTS HAVE
THEIR PRENATAL WITH US SOME OF
THEM HAVE IT WITH OTHER
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS AROUND
LA AND EVEN OTHER ORGANIZATIONS --
BUT WHAT'S REALLY CLEAR IS THAT
WE'RE AND SOME OF THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS DON'T PROVIDE
FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES RIGHT
THEY ARE ORGANIZATIONS THAT THAT
SIMPLY STAY OUT OF THAT SPACE --
AND BUT WE'RE VERY CLEAR FOR
INSTANCE IN OUR AFFILIATION WITH
THEM THAT THEIR CLIENTS WILL
RECEIVE COMPREHENSIVE FAMILY
PLANNING SERVICES AFTER DELIVERY.
THAT THEY WILL BE OFFERED A WIDE
RANGE OF FAMILY PLANNING OPTIONS
WHEN THEY'RE HAVING THEIR THIRTY
SIX THIRTY SEVEN WEEK VISITS
WITH OBSTETRICIANS AND MIDWIVES.
OF BECAUSE THAT STANDARD OF CARE
AND THAT EVIDENCE BASE THAT WE
FOLLOW WILL NOT VERY -- BECAUSE
A PARTNERSHIP THAT WE ENGAGE IN.
I THINK THE SOME OF THE EFFORTS
THAT HAVE BEEN UNDERTAKEN.
BY OUR FANTASTIC OUR REGION
HEALTH EDUCATION TEAM TO WORK
WITH VARIOUS FOUNDATIONS TO HOLD
CLASSES AND PARENTING CLASSES
AND THE DADDY BOOT CAMP AND NOW
LAUNCHING IN AREAS FOR THE LGBT
Q. AYE POPULATION -- WHERE WE
HAVE A INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CHOOSING US FOR GENDERLESS
EXPERIENCES PART OF THEIR -- AS
PART OF THEIR DELIVERY CARE AND
EXPANDING THEIR FAMILIES OF ARE
ALL TYPES OF INNOVATIONS THAT W
HAVE UNDER WAY -- BUT MOST
NOTABLY I THINK THE INNOVATION
IN THIS SPACE IS PARTIALLY QUITE
SIMPLE IT'S GIVING THE PATIENT
WITH THE PATIENT IS AFTER -- AND
NOT WHAT WE'RE AFTER SO -- IT'S
SORT OF THE NEXT LEVEL OF THE
THE GOLDEN RULE RIGHT IF THE
GOLDEN RULE IS TREATING OTHERS
HOW YOU WISH TO BE TREATED THE
PLATINUM ROLE IS TREATING PEOPLE
HAVE A WISH TO BE TREATED.
AND SO THAT'S THE MAXIMUM BY
WHICH REALLY WERE LIVING AND HOW
WE'RE PROVIDING THIS CARE.
SO -- OUR AFFILIATES HAVE WORKED
REALLY HARD WITH YOU ALL TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS TELEMEDICINE FOR
OUR PATIENTS.
AND WE WILL BE ABLE TO USE THAT
FOR SO MANY THINGS INCLUDING
MEDICATION ABORTIONS -- TRANS
HEALTH BEHAVIOR HEALTH SO WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED WE ARE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT WE ALSO SO
MUCH INNOVATION HAS COME FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
NOW HAVE ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IS WHAT'S CALLED PP DIRECT AND
SO THAT YOU CAN ORDER YOUR PILLS
ONLINE AND THAT CAME FROM
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THIS IS WHERE.
SO MUCH INNOVATION OCCUR SO YOU
CAN GET YOUR PILLS YOU CAN HAVE
AN S. T. I. TEST SENT TO YOUR
HOUSE AND THEN WE'LL SEND YOU
MEDICATION IS IF YOU NEED IT AND
THAT WAS REALLY CREATED.
HERE AND IT'S NOW IN ALMOST
EVERY STATE IN THE COUNTRY AND
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
BUT I THINK MEETING PATIENTS
WHERE THEY'RE AT AND THAT MEANS
IF YOU'RE IN A RURAL AREA BEING
ABLE TO USE TELEHEALTH BUT THEY
HAVE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THAT.
AND OF COURSE WE HAVE TO GET
REIMBURSED FOR THAT CARE IN
ORDER TO KEEP OUR DOORS OPEN.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND ALL OF THOSE AREAS.
YOU FOR YOUR ON GOING WORK -- SO
MY LAST QUESTION IS.
WHAT ELSE YOU WHAT CAN WE DO --
YOU KNOW WHAT CAN WE DO WE TALK
A LITTLE ABOUT IT BUT IS THERE
ANYTHING LEFT THAT YOU THINK WE
CAN DO REGULATORY WITH THE
REGULATORY PROCESS FINANCIALLY.
THROUGH LEGISLATION TO SUPPORT
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH ACCESS IN
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
BORN WITH. ONE THING YOU CAN
KEEP HEARING IS KEEP HAVING
THESE HEARINGS AND ELEVATING
THIS CONVERSATION IN A WAY --
AND ENGAGING PEOPLE FROM A WIDE
VARIETY OF CARE PROVIDERS
COMMUNITY ACTIVISTS IN A WAY TO
MAKE SURE BY DOING THIS YOU HELP
US INTEGRATE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE INTO.
WHAT IS JUST HEALTHCARE AND THE
D. STIGMATIZATION OF SEXUAL
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS
REALLY A CRITICAL STEP FORWARD --
I THINK WE CAN I THINK YOU CAN
DO MORE -- IN THE AREA OF MAKING
SURE THAT EVIDENCE BASED
SEXUALITY EDUCATION.
OF WHAT HAPPENS IN ALL OF OUR OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT -- THAT THE SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTER EXPANSION --
THAT FUNDING FOR THAT WOULD BE
CRITICAL MEAN JUST GETTING INTO
THAT SETTING WHERE --
PARTICULARLY TEENS ARE ABLE TO
INTERACT WITH A LICENSED
CLINICIAN AND A TRAINED
CLINICIAN -- TO RECEIVE EVIDENCE
BASED SERVICES AND A NON
JUDGMENTAL AND PRIVATE
ENVIRONMENT -- IS.
IT JUST IT JUST GOES SO MUCH
FURTHER DOWN -- EVEN THE STEPS
WE ALWAYS TAKE TO HAVE TEENAGERS
SPEAK TO CLINICIANS WITHOUT
PARENTS PRESENT ONCE THEY REACH
REPRODUCTIVE AGE I MEAN IT'S A
AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE AND OF
COURSE STABILIZING.
THE FUNDING SO WHATEVER YOU WISH
TO APPROPRIATE TO EXPAND SEXUAL
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH I THINK WE
ALL EXCEPT -- WITHOUT QUESTION.
FANTASTIC I I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING THAT YOU SAID AND
REIMBURSEMENT FOR SEX EDUCATION
IN ALL THE SETTINGS THAT WE
PROVIDE IT WOULD BE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND VERY HELPFUL TO
STABILIZING.
THE FUNDING BUT ALSO THINGS THAT
KEEP US UP AT NIGHT -- ARE
THINGS ABOUT THE SAFETY OF OUR
STAFF AND OUR PATIENTS AND THEN
BEING ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
PROVIDERS THROUGH THE LOAN
REPAYMENT.
AND INCREASED ACCESS FOR THAT
WOULD BE INCREDIBLY HELPFUL
BECAUSE SALARIES AND LOAN
REPAYMENT ARE WHAT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE WHEN I STARTED I HAD
THIRTY FIVE NURSE PRACTITIONER
HOPE OPENINGS.
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO INCLUDE
FILLED MOST OF THOSE POSITIONS
BUTWE DID IT THROUGH A MULTIPLE
THINGS AND ALSO HAVING A
RESOURCE FOR LOAN REPAYMENT
WOULD MAKE A HUGE HUGE
DIFFERENCE.
BECAUSE IF WE HAVE PROVIDERS
WERE OUT THERE PROVIDING CARE
MEETING OUR PATIENTS WHERE
THEY'RE AT SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANKS FOR GETTING THIS
COMMITTEE TOGETHER BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AND WHEN I TALK
TO OTHER.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD FOLKS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THEY DO SEE
CALIFORNIA AS THE BEACON OF
LIGHT AND HOPE IN REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE AND
JOINING US AND PROVIDING ALL
THIS FABULOUS INFORMATION MY
LIST OF THINGS THAT WE CAN DO IS
GROWING WHICH IS WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU
.
I AM GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAREER
TO FACILITATE THIS THIRD PANEL
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
EVERYBODY SETTLING IN -- GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN -- THIS IS OUR
THIRD PANEL ADDRESSING THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE NEEDS
OF THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY AND
JOINING US TODAY IS LOUD ABOUT I
GUESS WHO IS ON THE BOTTOM OF
THOUGHT US FROM ABOUT A STAFF.
OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD LOS
ANGELES.
LOUDER HE MENACE WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA THAT THE NEST FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE -- CARMELLA.
AT THE END OF OUR CO THE CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION.
AND LADY DO A SALAZAR WHO IS A
PATIENT ADVOCATE AND I'LL TAKE
ANOTHER MOMENT A PRIVILEGE TO
INDICATE THAT.
MISS HE MENACE WHO IS THE E. D.
OF OF CALIFORNIA LOOKING UP.
FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE WAS THE
SPONSOR OF OUR BILL AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY FOUR WHICH WOULD HAVE.
CREATED A COMPENSATION PROGRAM
FOR FOR STERILIZATION THAT
OCCURRED HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO TO OUR IT ON THE
STATE'S AGREED GISTS.
EUGENICS LAWS THAT IMPACTED
LATINO WOMEN AND THOSE THAT WERE
INCARCERATED UNFORTUNATELY.
THAT BILL WAS HELD IN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BUT WE
ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUING THE
WORK NECESSARY IN FACT.
SOUND FROM MY OFFICE IS HERE AND
WE HAVE COPIES OF THE FACT SHEET
OF THE BILL'S SAM IF YOU WANT TO
PASS IT OUT.
SO THAT YOU HAVE AN IDEA AS TO
WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THAT WAS AND
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN THE FUTURE.
SO WITH THAT SAID I WANT TO TURN
IT OVER TO THE PANEL AND LET YOU
LADIES GET STARTED ON WHAT YOU
WOULD LIKE -- TO DISCUSS I'M NOT
SURE WHAT.
ORDER BUT WE CAN START WITH.
KAMALA WHY DON'T WE START WITH
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO SUCH A
CRITICAL ISSUE AND BRING TO THE
HEALTH CENTER PERSPECTIVE ON THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
MY NAME'S KAMALA CUSTOMER GARCIA
PRESIDENCY OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION ALSO
KNOWN AS CP CA WHERE THE
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING OVER.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE PROVIDING
COMPREHENSIVE PRIMARY CARE
SERVICES TO NEARLY SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT'S ONE IN SIX
CALIFORNIANS GETTING THEIR
HEALTH CARE AT A COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTER.
AND CP SAY ALONG WITH OUR
AFFILIATE CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES ARE HEAVILY
INVESTIGATED INVESTED FUZION
ADVOCATING FOR THE RIGHTS OF OUR
HEALTH CENTER PATIENTS.
INCLUDING IMMIGRANTS TO ENSURE
THAT HEALTH CENTERS CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE CARE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
I'D LIKE TO JUST GIVE IT A VERY
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE HEALTH
CENTER PATIENT POPULATION A AND
IN PARTICULAR THE MISSION OF THE
QUEEN HEALTH CENTERS VERY
RELEVANT TO THIS COMMITTEE IN
THE QUESTION BECAUSE COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS MISSION.
IS TO TREAT EVERYONE WHO WALKS
THROUGH THEIR DOORS THAT'S
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY THEIR ACCESS TO COVERAGE OR
COURSE THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
AND COMMUNITY HEALTH SCANNERS
ARE PROVIDING CARE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION WHICH 76%
OF OUR PATIENTS BEING AT OR
BELOW 20% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL.
IN OVER 70% BEING FROM
COMMITTEES OF COLOR IN FACT 55%
OF HEALTH CENTER PATIENTS ARE
LIKE THE NOTE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE SERVING OVER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOMELESS AND
CLOSE TO SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
MIGRATORY FARMWORKERS SO.
BEATING THE NEEDS OF SPECIAL
POPULATIONS AND THE RURAL
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IS VERY CRITICAL ROLE
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS ARE
PLAYING IN A REAL COMMUNITIES IN
FACT COMMITTEE HEALTH AND IT
MIGHT BE THE ONLY SOURCE OF CARE.
OF EVERYBODY IN THAT COMMUNITY.
AND AND JUST TO KEEP IN MIND IN
THE MEDICAID PROGRAM WE ARE
SERVING ONE IN THREE MEDIC HELP
PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA THEY'RE
GETTING THE CARE AT COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS.
SO ASSURING THE FULL SPECTRUM OF
SERVICES AND CARE TO THIS
POPULATION IS CRITICAL AND
THAT'S EVERYTHING FROM MEDICAL
DENTAL TO BEHAVIORAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE.
HEALTH CARE AND ALONG WITH THE
NAY BILLING SERVICES SUCH AS
TRANSPORTATION DIETARY
COUNSELING WICK SERVICES AND
ENROLLMENT SUPPORT.
SO WE ARE -- VERY PROUD OF THE
VERY CRITICAL ROLE WE'RE PLAYING
PROVIDING COMPREHENSIVE PRIMARY
PREVENTIVE CARE TO A VERY
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF
CALIFORNIANS.
NOW WHAT WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY IS -- VERY CRITICAL NAME
SO PLEASE AT A SPECIFIC PANEL ON
ACCESS TO IMMIGRANTS OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH IS BEING
DISCUSSED TODAY AND IT COULDN'T
BE.
MORE TIMELY A RIGHT NOW GIVEN
THE ASSAULT THAT ARE THE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY IS UNDER IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONALLY -- CERTAINLY THE A
NEGATIVE RHETORIC AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AS LEAD TO AND AND
POLICIES OF LEAD TO INCREASE
RATES BY I SAID IT'S BECAUSE THE
BEARD DISTRUST ANXIETY AMONG OUR
PATIENTS.
AND INCLUDING CITIZENS IN
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE IN MIXED
STATUS FAMILIES.
AND IT'S FURTHER EXACERBATED BY
POLICY CHANGES THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN PUSHING
INCLUDING CHANGES TO PUBLIC
CHARGE FAMILY SEPARATION
MISHANDLING OF ASYLUM SEEKERS
AND REFUGEES PUTTING REGULAR LET
REGULATIONS IN PLACE THAT HINDER
THE ABILITY.
OF INDIVIDUALS TO MIGRATE TO
THIS COUNTRY OR STAY IN PLACE
THEY'RE ALREADY HERE AND
SPECIFICALLY -- THE PUBLIC
CHARGE RULES THAT WERE LEAKED IN --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN HAD LED TO A
NUMBER OF OUR HEALTH CENTERS.
REPORTING AN INCREASE IN MISTER
CAMPBELL'S APPOINTMENTS OR
REPORTS OF PATIENTS BEING DIS
ENROLLED FROM PROGRAMS I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT A TOUCH ON
THIS VERY CRITICAL PENDING
FEDERAL POLICY.
ON THAT IF -- PUT INTO PLACE
WHICH WE DO ANTICIPATE WILL BE A
VERY -- VERY SIGNIFICANT BARRIER
TO INDIVIDUALS ACCESSING HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND WHAT THE
PUBLIC CHARGE A DRUG IF I MIGHT
JUST BRIEFLY I'M STATE THAT BUT
THE PUBLIC CHARGE -- IS
IMMIGRATION LAW THAT DETERMINES
IT'S IT'S A DEVICE USED TO
DETERMINE WHETHER INDIVIDUALS
BECOME DEPENDENT ON GOVERNMENT
SERVICES WHEN DETERMINING THEIR
STATUS IN PARTICULAR HAS TO DO
WITH CHANGES FOR ENTRANCE OR RE
ENTRY INTO THE UNITED STATES OR
BECOMING A LAWFUL PERMANENT
RESIDENTS.
ACTUALLY PUBLIC CHARGES NOT IT
AFFECT INDIVIDUALS BECOMING
CITIZENS BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
CONFUSION -- BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT IT IMPACTS INDIVIDUALS
DIFFERENTLY IN A VERY CRITICAL
PIECE OF THIS CHANGE TO BE AWARE
OF IS AND HOW CARE THEY ARE
LOOKING AT USING ACCESS TO
SERVICES LIKE MEDICAID.
AS SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE TAKEN
TO CONSIDERATION TO DEEM AN
INDIVIDUAL A PUBLIC CHARGE THIS
IS VERY CRITICAL WITH LOOKING AT
ACCESS TO CARE FOR IMMIGRANTS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
HEALTHCARE IN GENERAL JUST
ACCESS TO SOCIAL SERVICES.
BECAUSE THIS PENDING PUBLIC
POLICY -- JUST AS PUT TREMENDOUS
BEER WITH IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
THAT'S WHAT THE IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO TOUCH ON THIS
POLICY AND KNOW THAT -- THIS HAS
A BIG IMPACT ON REPRODUCTIVE
SERVICES AND HEALTH CARE
SERVICES OVER ALL.
SO WE REALLY THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
THAT WE NEED TO FOCUS OUR WORK
AND MAKE SURE EVERYTHING THAT
WE'VE DONE TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
CARE ISN'T AN DONE BY THIS.
IMMIGRANT ANTI IMMIGRANT
ENVIRONMENT AND THESE A PROPOSED
POLICIES AND CALIFORNIA HAS
WORKED VERY HARD AND IS -- AS A
SAID BEACON FOR THE COUNTRY IN
TERMS OF THE WORK WE ARE DOING
TO PROTECT OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND EXPAND STAYS
BASE PUBLIC BENEFITS SERVICES
THIS IS TREMENDOUS.
THIS LEGISLATURE IN OUR
GOVERNORS TO BE COMMENDED FOR
THE TREMENDOUS WORK IN THAT
REGARD HOWEVER.
POLICIES LIKE THIS PUBLIC CHARGE
RULE TO COME DOWN ANY.
DAY WILL ONLY SERVE TO UNDERMINE
THESE POLICIES AND CONTINUE TO
HAVE A DETRIMENTAL IMPACT ON
IMMIGRANT ACCESS.
SO OUR COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA AND NATIONALLY ARE
BE MENTALLY AGAINST THIS CHANGE
THAT WOULD EXPAND THE DEFINITION
OF WHO BECOME A PUBLIC CHARGE
AND THE LIST OF PUBLIC BENEFITS
THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED.
AND THAT DETERMINATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION AT THE DIRECTION OF
OUR MEMBER HEALTH CENTERS HAS
BEEN LEADING ADVOCACY EFFORTS
PARTICULARLY COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTER MOVEMENT AGAINST THE
PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE PUBLIC
CHARGE RULE IT'S VERY CRITICAL
WE'VE BEEN WORKING BOTH
NATIONALLY AND WITH IN
CALIFORNIA. TO PROVIDE
EDUCATIONAL AND TRAINING
RESOURCES TO HEALTH CENTERS AND
PROVIDERS TO TO PREPARE THEM FOR
THE WORST CASE SCENARIO THAT
THEY MIGHT ENCOUNTER.
IN TERMS OF IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT -- SO WE'VE DONE
EVERYTHING FROM HELP OUR STAFF
ESTABLISH -- REPORT RISK PLANS
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
TRAINED ON IMMIGRATION POLICY
I'M WORKING WITH HEALTH CENTERS
TO PUT POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
IN PLACE REGARDING COOPERATION
OR NOT COOPERATING WITH ICE --
AND CERTAINLY BECAUSE OF ICE IS
NOT ALLOWED ON OUR SAFE SPACES
AND WITHOUT A JUDICIAL WARRANT
OR COURT ORDER -- PLAYED A LOT
OF ROLE IN HELPING TO EASE THE
FEAR AMONG OUR PATIENTS HEALTH
CENTER PATIENTS ARE IN
TREMENDOUS FEAR ABOUT
PARTICIPATING IN PUBLIC BENEFITS --
DUE TO THE ANTI IMMIGRANT
CLIMENT SO WE ARE INVOLVED IN
THE IMMIGRANT ACCESS TO PUBLIC
BENEFITS WORK GROUP AND A PLAYED
A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH IMMIGRANT ADVOCATES LIKE
THOSE.
AROUND THE TABLE TO BETTER
INFORM THE COMMUNITY ABOUT THIS
RULE AND ULTIMATELY -- SO THAT
INDIVIDUALS CAN EVALUATE THE
IMPACT ON THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
SO THIS WORK IS VERY CRITICAL OF
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OUR COALITION PARTNERS IN
PREPARATION FOR THIS FINAL RULE
THE COULD BE RELEASED.
ANY DAY -- WE HAVE A STATEWIDE
RESPONSE PLAN TO ISSUE MEDIA
STATEMENTS IMMEDIATELY TO HELP
AND FORMER NETWORKS OF WHERE TO
GO TO GATHER RESOURCES.
ALSO ENCOURAGING OUR HEALTH
CENTERS TO CREATE THEIR OWN
RESEARCH PLANS AS WELL AS
COORDINATED WITH COUNTY AND WE
ARE ARE COURTING THE COUNTIES
AND STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES.
SO IT'S REALLY CRITICAL THE
MESSAGING THAT WE DO AROUND THIS.
AND MAKE SURE THAT INDIVIDUALS
ARE ALSO REFERRED TO OF THE
LEGAL RESOURCE THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO NEED TO ALSO EVALUATE
THE IMPACT.
THIS WILL HAVE ON THEIR
INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES.
SO THERE IS A LOT OF WORK TO DO
AHEAD IN THIS ARENA THE I THINK
THAT WE'RE JUST.
WHEN THIS RULE DROPS WE'RE GOING
TO SEE US INCREDIBLE TREMENDOUS
FEAR AND IT'S GOING TO HAVE A
HUGE BERRY ON ACCESS TO CARE NOT
ONLY FOR THE IMMIGRANT
POPULATION BUT FOR THE RIVERS
POPULATIONS IN LOW INCOME
POPULATIONS?
CERTAINLY THAT COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS SERVED OTHER PROVIDERS
YOU SEE AROUND THIS TABLE.
SO I I REALLY WANT TO COMMEND
THIS COMMITTEE FOR SHINING LIGHT
ON THIS VERY CRITICAL ISSUE AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND CERTAINLY OF THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE AND WE KNOW
WILL CONTINUE. TO BE LEADERS NOT
ONLY IN THE STATE BUT FOR THE
COUNTRY AND FOR THAT WE ARE JUST
SO IMMENSELY PROUD AND SO
MENTALLY GRATEFUL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS A SANTA
GARCIA MISSILES ARE.
HI -- MY NAME'S LE LET OURSELVES
ARE -- AND UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS -- AND I'M CURRENTLY
HERE UNDER DEFERRED ACTION FOR
CHILDHOOD ARRIVALS -- I I GREW
UP IN THE BAY AREA I HAVE CALLED
OAKLAND MY HOME SINCE I WAS.
FIVE IN TWENTY TWELVE I WAS IN
THE MIDDLE OF A STATUS
ADJUSTMENT -- AND I WAS WAITING
ON A RESPONSE FROM --
IMMIGRATION AND AND IN EARLY
TWENTY THIRTEEN RECEIVED A
LETTER WITH THE DEPORTATION DATE --
I WAS TOTALLY NOT PREPARED TO
HANDLE THE IMPLICATIONS OF THAT
LETTER I SENT AN EMAIL TO MY
LAWYER AND I WENT ON ABOUT MY
DAY TO DAY LIFE -- THE FOLLOWING
DAY I HAD AN ANNUAL WELL WOMAN
APPOINTMENT AT MY LOCAL PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
AND WAS SITTING WAITING FOR THE
DOCTOR TO COME IN AND SEE ME --
WHEN THE NURSE CAME IN TO LET ME
KNOW THAT THEY WOULD BE UNABLE
TO PERFORM MY EXAM BECAUSE I WAS
PREGNANT -- I DIDN'T BELIEVE IT
I SAID NO PLEASE GO CHECK AGAIN.
AND BECAUSE THAT WAS MY PRIMARY
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER AT THE TIME
THEY'RE LIKE WE KNOW YOUR BIRTH
CONTROL WE'VE RAN THE TEST THREE
TIMES YOU'RE ACTUALLY PREGNANT --
THE NURSE SAID THEY WOULD GIVE
ME TIME TO GET DRESSED AND COME
BACK TO TALK TO ME ABOUT MY
OPTIONS.
THE MINUTE SHE CLOSE THE DOOR --
I BROKE DOWN SOBBING ALL OF A
SUDDEN THAT LATER BECAME REAL TO
ME -- AND IN WHAT FELT LIKE
ETERNITY PROBABLY CLOSE TO FIVE
MINUTES ADD TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
I WANTED FOR MY LIFE WHAT I WANT
FOR MY FUTURE AND WHAT I WANT MY
FAMILY TO LOOK LIKE.
AND WHAT I KNEW IS THAT I DID
NOT WANT TO HAVE A CHILD UNDER
THAT DEGREE OF UNCERTAINTY WHAT
I KNEW IS THAT I DO NOT WANT TO
HAVE A FAMILY UNDER THE THREAT
OF DEPORTATION.
AND WHAT I KNEW IS THAT I DID
NOT HAVE THE EMOTIONAL CAPACITY
TO FIGHT A DEPORTATION CASE AND
BE PREGNANT.
WHEN A NURSE CAME BACK IN I MADE
AN APPOINTMENT WITHOUT
CONSULTING ANYONE AND TWO DAYS
LATER I HAD AN ABORTION?
MY ABORTION WAS COMPLETELY
ROUTINE UNEVENTFUL ASK ALL
ABORTION SHOULD BE -- LIFE IS
COMPLICATED ENOUGH ACCESSING
YOUR HEALTH CARE SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO BE -- AND THAT WAS THE BEST
DECISION THAT I COULD HAVE DONE
FOR MYSELF AT THE TIME.
I KNOW MY EXPERIENCE IS UNIQUE
FOR A LOT OF UNDOCUMENTED --
PEOPLE BECAUSE WHEN I GREW UP
HERE I UNDERSTOOD HOW TO ACCESS
HEALTH CARE I UNDERSTOOD THAT.
EVEN THOUGH I WAS ON DOCUMENTED
AN UNEMPLOYED AND UNINSURED I
CAN GO TO A LOCAL PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND RECEIVE THE
SERVICES THAT I NEEDED.
I LIVE IN THE BAY AREA SO I DID
NOT HAVE TO EXPERIENCE SERVICE
SILOS -- AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
THE EXPERIENCE THAT ANY PERSON
WHO NEEDS TO ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE SHOULD
HALF I SHOULD NOT BE THE AN
ANOMALY.
FOR PEOPLE IN GENERAL AND
SPECIFICALLY FOR UNDOCUMENTED
FOLKS WHO ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW.
TO BEST -- LIVE THEIR LIFE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THANK YOU MISS ALICE ARE THOSE
AN INCREDIBLY POWERFUL TESTIMONY
AND YOU REPRESENT STORIES THAT
ARE MUCH NEEDED TO BE HEARD
THANK YOU.
MISS ARGUS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK ABOUT THE WORK THAT THE
PROMOTE THOUGH IT AS TO ATTEND
PARA -- MY NAME IS LEVEL ABOUT I
GUESS AND I'M A SENIOR HEALTH
EDUCATOR WITH TAMPA WHO LOS
ANGELES -- WELL PROMOTE TAUGHT
US PROMOTE ORDERS ARE WOMEN IN
THE COMMUNITY WHO ARE WELL
RESPECTED.
IN LEADERS AND HAVE A DEEP
PASSION FOR TRANSFORMING THEIR
COMMUNITY.
THEN THEY GO THROUGH A RIGOROUS
TRAINING IN SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH WITH US AT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD LOS ANGELES.
AND THEN THE GOLD AND TALK TO
OTHER WOMEN AND MEN IN THE AND
FAMILIES IN THE COMMUNITY --
PROMOTED AS HAVING GAINED
SIGNIFICANT IMPORTANCE IN THE
WAY THEY THEY CARE IS DELIVERED
IN THE UNITED STATES FOR LATINOS
IN THE LAST TWO DECADES.
N. AS WE KNOW LATINOS ARE THE
FASTEST GROWING ETHNIC GROUP IN
THE US AND ONE WOULD SELL AND
ONE WITH SOME OF THE LARGEST
HEALTH DISPARITIES.
AND CITIZENSHIP LANGUAGE AND
FAMILY ID WITH THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM ARE SOME OF THE MOST
COMMON BARRIERS. TO ACCESS CARE
FOR LATINOS.
ED THAT DEALS ALSO ARE TWO TO
THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY THAN THE
REST OF THE POPULATION TO BE AND
THEN SHARED.
WE ED PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
THE PROMOTE THOUGH IT IS THE
PROMOTED AS WE REACH OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE EVERY YEAR IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND WE GO TO PARKS COMMUNITY
CENTERS SCHOOLS APARTMENT
BUILDINGS DURING THE WEEK
WEEKENDS NIGHTS MORNINGS.
OF WE NEED PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE
AT AND WE GO TO THE HARDEST TO
REACH POPULATIONS.
OF A COMMUNITIES WE ALSO HAVE
OUR COLLABORATION WITH THE
MEXICAN CONSULATE WHERE UP
BESIDES PROVIDING EDUCATION IN
SPANISH ABOUT SECTION
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH STD
PREVENTION.
EVERY MONTH WE HAVE A CLINIC
WITHOUT WALLS WHERE PEOPLE CAN
ACCESS ON HEALTH SCREENINGS AT
THE SITE.
AND WE EITHER FROM A THOUGHT AS
OF PROVIDE SPACES TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT SEXUAL
HEALTH REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
WE ALSO TALK ABOUT FAMILY
COMMUNICATION ABOUT SEXUALITY WE
TALK ABOUT HOW TO EMBRACE AND
CELEBRATE OUR LGBT Q. CHILDREN
SO THEY CAN THRIVE.
SO THE PROMOTERS REALLY.
DISPEL MYTHS ABOUT SEXUALITY
THEY TALK ABOUT SEXUAL HEALTH
THE NORMAL AYE SCREENINGS WE
PROVIDE RESOURCES WE HELP
NAVIGATE SYSTEMS WE COMPANY
PEOPLE IN GIVEN THE CLIMATE OF
FEAR THAT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT --
WE ALSO SEE THAT IN THE
BEGINNING OF THIS ADMINISTRATION
LIKE THERE WERE LESS AT TEN THEN
SEEN OUR CLASSES LIST PEOPLE
ATTENDING EVEN AT THE PERRANCE
CENTER WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
VERY SAFE SPACE AT THE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS AND SCHOOLS
IN GENERAL.
OR PEOPLE MOTHERS DIDN'T WANT TO
PROVIDE -- THEIR NAMES -- ANY
INFORMATION OR ACCESS SERVICES --
BUT A PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
HAS INVESTED IN THIS MODEL SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE AND THAT
TAKES A LOT OF COMMITMENT FROM
THE C. ALL FROM THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FROM.
FROM THE SENIOR MANAGEMENT.
TO SEOUL AS THE PROMOTE THOUGHT
I'M MODEL HAS A LOT OF IMPACT IN
I DECREASING HELD -- DISPARITIES
IS A CULTURALLY SENSITIVE.
UP FROM ABOUT US LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITIES THEY ARE INVESTED IN
THE COMMUNITIES.
AND THEY ARE GREAT ASSETS A IN A
MEMBER PRODUCTIVE HEALTH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS ARGUS MISS
HUMANNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- I'M NOT A HE
MENACE AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA LETTING US
FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE OR CLR
J. -- I WAS ALSO BROUGHT UP IN
THE REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
MOVEMENTS SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR AND I'VE BEEN A PROUD --
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE ADVOCATE
SINCE THAT TIME -- SEALER J. THE
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION COMMITTED
TO HONORING THE EXPERIENCES OF
LATINOS AND THAT THE NEXT
PERSON'S TO UPHOLD OUR DIGNITY
OUR BODIES ARE SEXUALITY IN OUR
FAMILIES.
WE BUILD THAT THE N. AS IN THAT
THE NEXT POWER AND CULTIVATE
LEADERSHIP THROUGH COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT POLICY ADVOCACY AND
COMMUNITY INFORMED RESARCH TO
ACHIEVE REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE --
WE ARE CURRENTLY THE ONLY LATINA
LED REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION IN CALIFORNIA
HOLISTICALLY ADDRESSING LATINOS
AND AT THE NEXT HEALTH AND WELL
BEING. FOR THE LAST FOURTEEN
YEARS WE HAVE SERVED AS A BRIDGE
BETWEEN PUBLIC POLICY AND THE
SEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
LATINOS IN CALIFORNIA WHO
REPRESENT. 19% OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION AND COMPRISE OVER 39%
OVER THE THIRD OF THE STATE'S
FEMALE POPULATION -- BASED ON US
OUR PRODUCTION STATE THE BY
TWENTY SIXTY LATINOS WILL
REPRESENT NEARLY HALF OF THE
FEMALE POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA
AND A THIRD OF THE FEMALE
POPULATION OF THE U. S..
BASED ON THESE PROJECTIONS IT IS
EVIDENT THAT THE HEALTH AND
PROSPERITY OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
NATION IS VERY MUCH LINKED TO
THE OVERALL WELL BEING OF
LATINOS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WE UTILIZE THE REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE FRAMEWORK WHICH IS
CREATED BY WOMEN OF COLOR BASED
ON THE HUMAN RIGHTS FRAMEWORK
AND BLACK FEMINIST THEORY TO
CENTER THE LIVED EXPERIENCES OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN.
OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE STRATEGY TO ENSURE
THAT ALL PEOPLE'S NEEDS ARE MET.
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES OF
IMMIGRANTS IN REGARDS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH REQUIRES US
TO UTILIZE THIS FRAMEWORK TO GET
A HOLISTIC PICTURE.
OF THESE COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE WAYS THAT
THEY ARE INTERSECTING ISSUES
THAT THEY EXPERIENCE
SIMULTANEOUSLY.
IMMIGRANTS ARE AN INTEGRAL PART
OF OUR NATIONAL FABRIC AND PART
OF EVERY COMMUNITY THERE ARE CO
WORKERS OR CLASSMATES.
OUR NEIGHBORS ARE LEGISLATORS.
ALMOST EVERY FAMILY HAS A
MIGRATION STORY.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO MORE
IMMIGRANTS ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
STATE.
OVER A QUARTER OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION IS FOREIGN BORN ABOUT
TWICE THE U. S. PERCENTAGE AND A
LITTLE OVER HALF OF THOSE TEN
MILLION IMMIGRANTS ARE LETTING
US -- ACCORDING TO ESTIMATES
FROM IMMIGRATION POLICY
INSTITUTE MORE THAN FOUR MILLION
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA HAVE AT
LEAST ONE IMMIGRANT PARENT.
AND THE VAST MAJORITYOF THESE
CHILDREN ARE US CITIZENS.
A REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE APPROACH
TO THE ISSUE OF A MAKE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH REQUIRES THAT WE CONSIDER
THE THREE TENANTS OF THE
FRAMEWORK.
THE RIGHT TO CONTROL OUR
FERTILITY AND HAVE ACCESS TO
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
CONTRACEPTIVE AND ABORTION
SERVICES ON DEMAND.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
COMPREHENSIVE SEX THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO OUR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
SCHOOLS.
THE RIGHT TO DECIDE TO HAVE
CHILDREN WITHOUT INTERFERENCE
FROM THE STATE OR OTHER
INSTITUTIONS.
AND THE RIGHT TO RAISE THE
CHILDREN WE HAVE AND SAFE AND
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT.
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE SEE JUSTICE
IS THE LEGACY OF THE STRUGGLE OF
BLACK INDIGENOUS AND OTHER
PEOPLE OF COLOR AGAINST GENOCIDE
SLAVERY FORCED BREEDING FOR
STERILIZATION STOLEN CHILDREN
AND RACIST IMMIGRATION AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE POLICIES AMONG
OTHER THINGS.
SO BASICALLY WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THE CONCRETE RESULTS THAT WE ARE
LIVING WITH FROM A SYSTEM BUILT
UPON NOT ONLY MISOGYNY BUT
RACISM AND WHITE SUPREMACY.
TODAY IN CALIFORNIA THAT MEANS
UNDERSTANDING THAT ALTHOUGH
CALIFORNIA IS PAINTED AS A
BEACON FOR REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
IN THE COUNTRY.
NOT EVERYONE HAS EQUAL ACCESS TO
SERVICES.
LANGUAGE IS STILL A BARRIER AS
WE HERE IN LOS ANGELES OFTEN
THERE ARE INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
COMING FROM MEXICO AND CENTRAL
AMERICA WHO ARE NOT SPEAKING
SPANISH.
AND THE LANGUAGE BARRIER --
OFTEN RESULTS IN CHILDREN BEING
REMOVED AND INADEQUATE ACCESS TO
SERVICES COURT PROCEEDINGS
ETCETERA.
INCOME IS STILL A BARRIER NOT
EVERYONE HAS HEALTH INSURANCE
GEOGRAPHY IS SUPERIOR WHEN
THEY'RE NOT SERVICES WITHIN A
REASONABLE -- RANGE FROM YOUR
HOME.
AND NOT TO MENTION THE CLIMATE
OF FEAR AND CONFUSION THAT THE
FEDERAL MINISTRATIONS
REGULATIONS AND POLICIES IS
GENERATING AN IMMIGRANT AND
OTHER COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
THE ATTEMPT TO ENTITLE TEN
FUNDING IT TO CHANGE THE PUBLIC
CHARGE RULE AS WELL AS THE
CURRENT POLICY OF SEPARATING
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE CHILDREN.
FROM THEIR FAMILIES AT THE
BORDER AND KEEPING THEM IN
TORTUROUS CONDITIONS HEIGHTENED
STRESS AMONGST IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND OTHERS.
RESULTING IN MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH CRISES.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS CENTER THE
NEEDS AND EXPERIENCES OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR IN OUR
STATE -- AND CREATE PRACTICAL
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES -- I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO TALK ABOUT -- WHAT
A GREAT JOB ADVOCATES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE DONE OVER THE
LAST FEW DECADES IN TERMS OF
MAKING GREAT STRIDES IN
INCREASING ACCESS IN THE STATE?
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT ALSO
REALIZE THAT DOESN'T EQUATE TO
PRACTICAL ACCESS AND ALL
COMMUNITIES -- ESPECIALLY IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES OR UNDER
REPRESENTED AND MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES -- ADDRESS RACISM
AND WHITE SUPREMACY THROUGH
LEGISLATION AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE --
ADDRESSING THE HISTORICAL WRONGS
PERPETRATED AGAINST PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA IS CRITICAL AND
CONTINUE TO WORK OUT WAYS TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES FROM FEDERAL TAX AND
TO EDUCATE AND INFORM THEM ABOUT
THESE EFFORTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR INVITING
ME TO BE HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU FOR THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION
CERTAINLY THAT NEEDS TO BE
SHARED ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE AND I WANT TO
GO BACK TO YOU -- FOR JUST A FEW
MINUTES TO DISCUSS THE ISSUE A
PUBLIC CHARGE AND THE WAY THAT --
SOME CLINICS ARE BEING IMPACTED
AND WHAT YOU'RE SEEING ON YOUR
END -- THAT YOU MAY NEED HELP ON
FROM THE LEGISLATURE -- WELL WE
ACTUALLY.
DID A SOME DATA TO LOOK AT THE
CHILLING EFFECT THAT WAS
HAPPENING ON OUR FAMILIES IN A
STUDY WITH THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN THAT CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM ASK SAYS TO
CARE WHILE BACK TO IT WAS
ACTUALLY PROVIDER SURVEY JUST TO
GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT
PROVIDERS REPORTED AMONG
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES WE SAW 90%
INCREASE IN ANXIETY AND FEAR DUE
TO DETENTION AND DEPORTATION.
70% INCREASE IN DEPRESSION
SYMPTOMS A 50% INCREASE AND
EXCITING AND DEPRESSION
DIAGNOSIS 25% INCREASE IN
SINKING MENTAL HEALTH CARE --
62% INCREASING CONCERNS ABOUT
ENROLLING IN PUBLIC BENEFIT
PROGRAMS SUCH AS WEAK AND
MEDICAID AND SO -- AND THIS
INCLUDES WITH THE CAN FEW I'M
REALLY MASS CONFUSION OF PEOPLE
COMING IN WITH THE FEAR CAUSING
THEM TO WANT TO CANCEL
APPOINTMENTS ARE ASKED TO BE
JUST ENROLLED IN PROGRAMS LIKE.
MEDICARE SO THOSE ARE THE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DOCUMENT FROM OUR A PROVIDERS
AND THIS.
ACTUALLY DOES PRESENT STRESS ON
PROVIDERS -- BECAUSE THE
PROVIDERS ARE ARE ALREADY --
CHARLIE YOU KNOW HAVES DRESS A
CHALLENGING POPULATION IN OUR
CHALLENGE WE GETTING THEM ACCESS
TO SPECIALTY CARE AND OTHER
SERVICES OVER CAPACITY IT'S
ALREADY A CHALLENGING POSITION
TO WORK WITH THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
BUT WHAT WE FOUND IN TALKING TO
OUR PROVIDERS ARE RESPONDING TO
THE SURVEY WHEN THE POPULATION
IS PARTICULARLY STRESSED AT THIS
LEVEL AND YOU AND FOR EXAMPLE OR
MENTAL HEALTH CAPACITY CANNOT
KEEP UP WITH THE DEMAND -- THIS
PUTS A TREMENDOUS STRESS ON
PROVIDERS SO THAT'S JUST AN
ADDITIONAL THING THAT WE ARE
SEEING IS ALREADY DISCUSSED THE
WORK FORCE CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE TO RECRUIT RETRAITE READ
RETAIN OUR PROVIDERS AND I JUST
KNOW WHEN OUR PATIENTS ARE
SUFFERING -- THE PROVIDERS WHO
ARE SO DEDICATED AND COMMITTED
TO THEM ARE SUFFERING AS WELL.
HAVE YOU -- CAN YOU SHARE MAY BE
ANYONE ON THE PANEL -- THE
PERSONAL STORY OF THE PUBLIC
CHARGE -- SITUATION AND HOW IT
IMPACTED FAMILIES OR WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD FROM.
FROM THE CLINICS ON THE GROUND.
I'M WELL I THINK DEFINITELY THE
FEAR AMONG CHILDREN IS SOMETHING
THAT IS SO HEARTBREAKING AND IT
WAS IT WAS DISCUSSES STATISTICS
ABOUT OUR CHILDREN THAT ARE IN
AT PARENTS THAT ARE WHAT LEAST
WHEN IMMIGRANTS VERY PROMINENT
IN OUR POPULATION.
I'M SO THERE'S A LOT OF FEAR
AMONG CHILDREN AND THAT IS
SOMETHING WE'RE HEARING -- BOTH
ANECDOTALLY AND ON AND I THINK
OUR SURVEY HELP TO SUPPORT THAT
IDEA SO THAT IS I THINK JUST A
MAJOR A MAJOR CONCERN -- AND
WHEN I JUST SAY ABOUT THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS NOT BEING ABLE TO
DRESS THEM I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
GET TO POLICY BUT THAT IS
CERTAINLY A FRUSTRATION WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
THAT.
A WELL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
SOMETHING WERE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE -- UNDER FEDERAL LAW
THAT THERE ARE POLICIES IN PLACE
THAT ARE IMPACTING OUR ABILITY
TO EXPAND OUR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SO IN THESE SITUATIONS
WITH THERE'S JUST A GROWING
TREMENDOUS NEED AND YET.
YEARS GETTING IN THE WAY IT'S
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING.
CAN I ASK OF THEIR OTHER
POLICIES THE YOU SEE THAT HAVE A
CHILLING EFFECT IN ADDITION TO
THE PUBLIC CHARGE ROLE WHETHER
COMING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OR OTHERWISE THAT ARE
REALLY.
BETTER CREATING BARRIERS TO
PEOPLE ACCESSING REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH TREATMENT.
WELL THE HOSTILITY TO THE
IMMIGRANT POPULATION THAT THAT'S
BEEN MENTIONED EVERYTHING FROM
THE SAME FAMILY SEPARATIONS AND
THE ANTI IMMIGRANT CLIMATE THE
PUBLIC CHARGES JUST ANOTHER
LAYER ON TOP OF A MULTI YEAR
ASSAULT THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE.
SO I THINK IT'S REALLY ALL THESE
POLICIES AND THAT'S ALSO PART OF
THE CONFUSION AND WHY THERE'S
THE DEED FOR EDUCATION AS WELL
BECAUSE THESE POLICIES ARE VERY
CONFUSING TO INDIVIDUALS.
RIGHT -- SO WE TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ARE LASTING ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION BEING -- AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF MAKING SURE
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE ARE
THERE OTHER THINGS THAT WE CAN
DO -- TO CREATE BETTER ACCESS --
BEYOND.
BEING PARTNERS IN EDUCATING
INFORMING ABOUT THE REALITY OF
THINGS IN PROVIDING
TRANSPORTATION AND SOME OF THE
THINGS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT YOUR
ANY THOUGHTS FOR US AND HOW WE
CAN SUPPORT YOU AND DECREASING
THOSE BARRIERS. ONE OF THE I DO
WANT TO MENTION THE MENTAL
HEALTH CARE IS BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS SO HUGE WE'RE FACING A
CRISIS OF INDIVIDUALS NEEDING
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH BUT THE
MAJOR PROVIDER CONSTITUENCY IN
THE STATE WHICH COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS THAT ARE WELL POSITIONED
TO PROVIDE.
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
DOING IT THE WAY THE INTEGRATED
INTO PRIMARY CARE WHICH EVIDENCE
SHOWS IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY
TO PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH.
BUT STATE POLICIES RIGHT NOW DO
NOT FACILITATE THE ABILITY OF
COMMITTEE HEALTH CENTERS TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES FOR EXAMPLE
WE ARE STILL NOT ABLE TO BILL
FOR MARRIAGE FAMILY THERAPIST
THIS IS THE MOST CULTURALLY
COMPETENT DIVERSE WORKFORCE IN
MENTAL HEALTH THAT EXISTS AS
MARRIAGE FAMILY THERAPIST.
WE ARE THE ONLY PROVIDER GROUP
THAT IS UNABLE TO BILL FOR THEM.
THAT IS A TRAGEDY IN STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THIS SITUATION AND
AND THE NEED FOR BILINGUAL
BICULTURAL PROVIDERS THAT'S A
POLICY THE COULD BE CHANGE WITH
THE STATE PLAN AMENDMENT THAT
THE STATE -- NEEDS TO SUBMIT SO
WE CAN MOVE ON THAT SO THAT'S
JUST A VERY CRITICAL POLICY
ANOTHER IS THE ABILITY TO BILL
FOR MENTAL HEALTH IN A PRIMARY
CARE VISIT ON THE SAME DAY.
I WENT TO A CLINIC IN NAPA THIS
IS A VERY LARGE FARM WORKER
POPULATION A BRAND NEW CLINICS
SLATED TO OPEN JUNE FIRST I WENT
AT THE I WHEN AT THE END OF MAY.
THEY HAD IT ALL SET UP WHERE THE
PRIMARY CARE.
OF THE THE MENTAL HEALTH ROOM
WAS INTEGRATED INTO THE PRIMARY
CARE A CLINICAL.
SPACE HOWEVER THE CLINIC CANNOT
BE REIMBURSED IF THEY IDENTIFY
DEPRESSION BEHIND EGGS IDEA
EVERYTHING THAT WAS MENTIONED.
AND WANT TO JUST HAND OFF TO A
WARM HAND OFF SAME DAY HAVE THAT
FAMILY THAT CHILD BE SEEN BY
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER WE CANNOT.
BILL FOR THAT SERVICE IF WE DO
IT ON THE SAME DAY EVEN THOUGH
KNOWING THAT IS THE BEST WAY TO
FACILITATE ACCESS.
SO LIKE I SAID THERE'S A MAJOR
BARRIERS AND IF THESE BEARS WERE
ELIMINATED IT WOULD GREATLY
ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS WHO ARE THE RIGHT.
PROVIDER TO SERVE THIS
POPULATION IN THE RIGHT WAY --
AND WE'D BE ABLE TO DO MORE TO
ADDRESSTHESE TREMENDOUS NEEDS
ARE THE MENTAL HEALTH PIECE
REALLY DOES NEED TO BE MENTIONED --
IN THIS CURRENT ENVIRONMENT
CRITICAL BARRIER SUPER HELPFUL
THANK YOU.
I WANTED TO ASK A QUESTION ON
CULTURAL COMPETENCY.
SO -- LET THE ENOUGH FAMILIES AT
THE NO FAMILIES TEND TO BE
SOMETIMES MORE CONSERVATIVE --
AND I'M WONDERING FROM THE
PROMOTE THOUGHT UP PERSPECTIVE
WHAT HAS BEEN THE GROWTH.
OF MORE LATINA MOTHERS GETTING
ENGAGED HOSPITAL THOUGHT AS AN
ACTUALLY ADVOCATING FOR
COMPREHENSIVE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE.
AND I'M SURE IT SEALED YOU CAN
ALL MISSING AS HE CAN ALSO
ATTEST TO THAT AS WELL.
WELL OUR PROGRAM HAS WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN NINETY
ONE IN WHAT WE SEE IS THAT
DESPITE THE BELIEF THAT.
WE ARE VERY CONSERVATIVE WHICH
WE ARE BUT WE ARE ALSO.
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT OUR FAMILY
AND THE HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN.
AND THE MOMENT YOU KNOW WE
STARTED OUR CLASSES IN THE
APARTMENT BUILDINGS WITH THE
WITH THE MOMS IN A LIVE.
AND SO THE MOMENT WE TALK ABOUT --
STD RATE AMONG THE YOU'LL SEE OF
NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES -- THE
PARENTS ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE CHILDREN SO THEY THEY ARE
VERY WILLING. TO TO AVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND THEN THEY SEE
IN THE PROMO TORA A LEADER A
MODEL AND THEY GET VERY EXCITED
WE PROVIDE -- EIGHT TO TWELVE
SESSIONS ABOUT ALL SORTS OF
THINGS YOU KNOW YOUR BODY
CONTRACEPTIVES A COMMUNICATION
ABOUT SEXUALITY ACCEPTING YOUR
LGBT CHILDHOOD TO THAT SOUL WE
BUILD TRUST AND PARENTS ARE VERY
OPEN LATINO PARENTS ARE VERY
OPEN THEY WANT THE BEST FOR
THEIR CHILDREN.
AND A LOT OF WOMEN APPROACH THE
PROMOTER AND SAY I WANT TO BE A
PROMOTE THOUGHT I WANT TO DO
WHAT YOU DO SO.-A THE WILLINGNESS THE OPENNESS
IS THERE.
A I WOULD SAY A WE USED.
TO IN THE NINETEEN NINETY ONE
NINETY TWO IN EAST LA A PEN PAL
USED TO KNOCK ON DOORS AND SAY
YOU DO WANT TO BE AT PROMOTING
COMMON TWENTY GET TRAINED.
AND THE PROMOTED AS LITTLE BY
LITTLE STARTED FROM.
TEACHING AT AN APARTMENT
BUILDINGS TO CALL TO THE PEN
SENSE I WANT TO GO TO THE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WITH MY CHILD
CLOSE I WANT TO GO TO THE MIDDLE
SCHOOL AT TODAY.
NOWADAYS EVERY YEAR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD CLOSE TO A HUNDRED
AND FORTY SCHOOLS IN THE US THE
SOLE -- IN ALSO WE HAVE A
WAITING LIST FOR WOMEN IN THE
COMMUNITY WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE A
PROMO TORA AND THEY KNOW THAT IS
HAS TO DO WITH SEXUAL HEALTH
WHICH IS.
ALMOST DOUBLE IN OUR CULTURE SO
WE SEE THOSE CHANGES AT THAT
LEVEL OF THE FAMILY LEVEL AND
THE IMPACT THAT THE PROMOTE
THOUGHT I HASH.
ON THEIR CUSSONS THE COMMODITIES
THAT THERE.
I IMMEDIATE ENVIRONMENT -- THEY
IMPACT THAT THEY HAVE.
WE SEE IT AS A RIPPLE EFFECT
REALLY AND THEY ARE EXCITED
ABOUT THESE THINGS.
AND ALSO THE HUSBANDS OR
PARTNERS YOU KNOW SOMETIMES
THERE'S RESISTANCE AT THE
BEGINNING WHERE YOU.
YOU KNOW BRING IN THESE
MATERIALS HEAD A HANDING OVER
CONDOMS OR HAVING THIS AND
THAT'LL ME PEACE YOU KNOW LIKE.
**** MODEL WHATEVER IT IS RIGHT
BUT THE HUSBANDS AND PARTNERS
AND FAMILY MEMBERS ALSO WARM UP
TO THE IDEA THEY SEE THE VALUE
OF THESE.
INFORMATION THE SHERRY IN AND
THEY SEE THE POSITIVE EFFECT OF
OF THESE KINDS OF OF PROGRAMS.
I I WOULD AGREE WITH WHAT WAS
BETTER SAYS -- BUT I ALSO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT -- WELL WE DO
HAVE -- FAMILIES THAT ARE VERY
CONSERVATIVE IN OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITIES I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ALSO COMPLICATE
THAT THAT SORT OF STEREOTYPE OF
WHO WE ARE BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
ALL THAT CONSERVATIVE IN FACT
YOU KNOW STUDIES SHOW THAT
LATINO PARENTS WANT THEIR
CHILDREN TO HAVE COME SIX THAT
EQUAL.
YOU KNOW OR SIMILAR RATES TO
OTHER COMMUNITIES -- AND THAT --
OFTENTIMES RELIGION IS NOT THE
MOST IMPORTANT FACT DECIDING
FACTOR IN MAKING DECISIONS
AROUND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH OR
THEIR REPRODUCTIVE LIFE.
AND SO I THINK YOU KNOW CONTINUE
TO PUT THAT FORWARD HERE IN THIS
BUILDING IN THE MEDIA IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE SOMETIMES IT'S JUST LACK
OF INFORMATION AND WANTING AND
NOT.
FEELING CONFIDENT ENOUGH TO
SHARE THE INFORMATION WITH THEIR
CHILDREN BUT WHEN I YOU KNOW
PROMOTE OTIS ARE ARE SHARING
INFORMATION AND TRAINING PARENTS --
THEN THEY CAN THEY CAN GAIN THAT
THAT CONFIDENCE AND THEY CAN
SPEAK WITH THEIR KIDS AND
THEY'RE ALSO INTERESTED IN THEIR
CHILDREN HAVING THAT EDUCATION
AT SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY WANT
THEIR KIDSTO BE SAFE WE WANT
OUR KIDS TO BE SAFE.
I WOULD LIKE TO CALL ON SOMEBODY
FROM THE AUDIENCE THAT'S OKAY.
MRS CELINDA VASQUEZ'S WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD LOS ANGELES
AND WE WERE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT -- SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH.
HEALTH CENTERS AND MAYBE IF WE
CAN TURN CAN WE TURN ON THAT
MICHAEL WHETHER.
THE SENT T STAND UP MY THANK
YOU.
I'M IN THE PREVIOUS PANEL THERE
WAS A DISCUSSION ON SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CARE CENTERS.
ROOSEVELT HIGH SCHOOL IS WHERE I
WENT TO SCHOOL IN IN BOYLE
HEIGHTS IT WAS A PROMOTE THOUGHT
I IN THE LATE NINETEEN NINETIES
THAT CAME TO MY SCHOOL IT WAS
ONE OF THE HIGH SCHOOLS.
THAT HAS A CHILD CARECENTER AND
WE WERE DISCUSSING AND I WOULD
LOVE FOR YOU TO SHARE THE
STATISTICS ON THE NUMBERS OF OF
PREGNANCY RATES WITHIN YOUNG LET
THE IN US -- AND HOW PLANNED
PARENTHOOD HAS PLAYED A ROLE
ONCE THE CLINIC IS AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL SURE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR CALLING ME UP FROM THE
AUDIENCE -- THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY I'M INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PANEL INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT -- SELECT COMMITTEE SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP --
SPECIFICALLY AT ROOSEVELT HIGH
SCHOOL SO PLANNED PARENTHOOD LOS
ANGELES AS MANY OTHER -- HEALTH
CENTERS HAVE HOW ARE
PARTICIPATING IN WELLNESS
CENTERS ON CAMPUS SAYS AND IN
PARTICULAR AT ROSE ABOUT WE
ACTUALLY HAD WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED IN THIS WAS PROBABLY OF
ABOUT ELEVEN TWELVE YEARS AGO.
THE NURSE AT THE SCHOOL CALLED
OUT PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND SAD
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
ISSUE WITH TEEN PREGNANCY -- I
THINK IT WAS RIGHT AROUND ADD
THAT THE PROM.
PRIMETIME -- THEY HAD ABOUT THIS
IS ANECDOTAL THEY HAD ABOUT
THIRTY POSITIVE PREGNANCY TEST
THAT THEY KNEW OF AND THEY THEY
ASK PLANNED PARENTHOOD TO COME
IN AND TO DO YOU WORK AT THE
SCHOOL SO.
WE DID THAT -- AND THE MODEL HAS
EVOLVED TREMENDOUSLY SINCE THE
SINCE THAT FIRST YEAR BUT THE
FOLLOWING YEAR THEY ONLY HAD
THREE POSITIVE PREGNANCY TEST SO
WE KNOW THOSE ARE THE THE THE
NUMBERS THAT WERE.
AB THAT THE DATA THAT WE HAVE
DATA.
FOR BUT THERE WERE JUST THEY
WENT FROM THIRTY TO THREE AND
ONE YEAR IN ONE YEAR THAT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WAS THERE
PROVIDING CLINICAL SERVICES.
WE'VE ALSO ESTABLISHED -- PURE
ADVOCATES WE'VE ALSO WERE IN THE
CLASSROOM SO IT'S A WRAPAROUND
MODELS.
WE HAVE PROMOTE THOUGHT AS SO
WE'RE SUPPORTING THE PARENTS
WERE SUPPORTING THE ACTUAL
STUDENTS FOR SUPPORTING THE
TEACHERS AND THEIR SERVICE SAYS
AND THAT REALLY THAT'S A MODEL
THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY WORKING
REALLY HARD TO EXPAND RIGHT NOW
IN LA U. ES DE UM.
AND NOT AT THE LAKE -- SCHOOLS
THE NON LA U. S. SCHOOL SO WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS OF ALL
THE MEN WILL BE I'M DOING THE
SAME WORK IN -- WE DO THIS NOW
AT HOLLYWOOD HIGH AND THEN WE
WILL BE OUT FIVE ADDITIONAL
SCHOOLS.
TWENTY NINETEEN THANK YOU AND
AND THANK YOU FOR LET ME CALL
YOU OUT LIKE THAT [inaudible]
IT WASN'T.
IT WAS AN HALLWAY CONVERSATION
THAT I THOUGHT WAS IMPORTANT TO
SHARE IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY
SHARING MODELS THAT ARE WORKING
AND HOW TO WE REPLICATE MODELS
THAT ARE WORKING ACROSS THE
STATE AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SO WHEN I THANK ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS FOR BEING HERE TODAY
PROVIDING YOUR INSIGHT I THINK
THAT -- THE LAST PANEL SAID
SOMETHING THAT WRAPS UP OUR
GOALS FOR THE DAY WHICH IS THAT
WE ALL CARE ABOUT THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF OUR CHILDREN AND
OUR FAMILIES AND THAT.
ENSURING THAT GOAL WE'RE GOING
TO GET.
TO THE BEST REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE MODEL IN THE COUNTRY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THIS COMMITTEES
GOING TO BE A HUGE PART OF THAT
SO THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING A
PART OF THAT TODAY -- THE LAST
THING THAT I LIKE TO DO IS I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
PUBLIC COMMENT BUT WE WILL OPEN
IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IF
ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE.
YES TWO MINUTES. FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THEN WE
WILL HAVE.
WE WILL CONCLUDE THIS M. HEARING
OF THIS LIKE MANY REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH AGAIN THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING